good evening everybody uh I'm councelor
War boys chair of Seer District Council
and I will be chairing the meeting
today before the meeting commences there
will now be a minut silence to remember
previous midu councilor Charles flatman
who has recently passed
away
for
right thank
you okay before the meeting starts um
continues I'd like to apologize to the
council for an unintentional mistake on
my part I was at a meeting at wam Ling
to show support for those affected by
the proposed pons routee who were
campaigning for an alternative route to
be chosen when I introduced myself as
chair of the
council after outlining the support of
the council for the residents I did not
make it clear when making political
statements that our speaking as gizan
wart counselor not as chair of the
council I'd like to show the council
that this will not occur again thank
you okay may I now remind you of some
domestic Arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs do not re-enter the building until
you are told it is safe to do so please
switch off all mobile mobile phones or
turn them to
silent I'd like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
when there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you're
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting Andor training purposes the
council members of the public and the
Press Barry Court film photograph of
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully
excluded can I remind members to speak
clearly into the microphones and to not
put their papers over the
microphones can I move to the agenda
please apologies for
absence thank you chair we we have
received apologies from councelor
Lavinia hadingham councelor Janet
Pearson councelor Keith scarf and
councelor David
napia are there any Declarations of
interest uh councilor bur um thank you
chair um as director of um free Port
East so Declaration of interest for
items 15 and 18 thank
you Council
prep uh yes thank you chair so uh as um
an employee of sty Market High School um
there may be uh an I may have an
interest in um items 15 uh sorry item 14
shelf
project uh Council Stringer thank you
chairman uh I'm a director of Gateway 14
limited so have an interest in item 15
thank
you coun Med
Council
V thank you chair yeah I understand that
all the directors of the um mids suff
holding company which owns Gateway 14
limited uh also need to uh declare their
interest that's me and some
others Council
L thank you chair um as a director of
Gateway 14 and suff at Holdings also uh
agenda item
15 and Council winch yeah the same as a
director of mic Holdings item 15 I'm not
sure if we have to declare as Holdings
board
but are
we item 15 thank you
Council any
[Music]
further thank you thank
you
uh uh item MC
2329 uh to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 20th of November for
accuracy only are there any issues with
accuracy uh could I have a proposal
please councilor
eurn could I have a second of
please
sorry Council
Carter you seconded yeah um uh can we
take the vote by a show of hands uh all
those in
favor that's
carried
uh something
for the interest
ofation interest coun
yes thank you members for your
Declarations of Interest I just want to
say that counselors who are directors on
the council's companies have
dispensation from the monitor
officer thank
you all right I refer you to paper MC
2330 for
noting
um on um t one item in particular
Tuesday the 19th of December the long
Service Awards
presentation um I was present and the
following officer receiv receives
officers received certificates for the
long service of the council 30 years
running Tracy Farthing commissioning and
procurement business partner 20 years
Stephanie B letting coordinator
supported living Leslie Thomas admin and
Technical Support Officer housing Sophia
cerly technical officer of food and
safety Sarah Scott senior planning
officer Julie Paul scheme manager
supported living uh Joanna Hart senior
Environmental Protection
Officer and finally I'd like to just
remind everyone that on Saturday the
27th of January is Holocaust Memorial
Day on the morning of the 27th of
January
1945 the housewitch birkenau camps still
held some 7,000 prisoners over a million
people deported to housewitch perish
there it is estimated that 6 million
Jews were exterminated in the death
camps 1.5 million of them were children
in total it is estimated that upwards of
17 million people are systematically
murdered by the Nazis in a program of
ethnic cleansing with the goal of
eradicating the Jewish Romany and and
Slavic peoples Holocaust day is a day of
remembrance and through observance unit
Us in working to prevent hatred bigotry
racism and
Prejudice thank
you I'd like to invite Council melon to
present his
update yes thank you chair um before I
uh read out these announcements um I was
also present at the uh the ceremony to
hand out certificates to to those staff
who' served a very large number of years
of service to the council and I think
they deserve a random
[Applause]
Applause uh I'll now move on to my
leaders announcements uh firstly an
update on the government payments after
storm babet it is three months since
storm B bet had a devastating impact on
our
communities rainfor events since for
many residents and businesses the
recovery is still
ongoing following the storm the
government announced flooded households
could apply for up to 500 to help with
costs and businesses up to
25,000 I'm happy to be able to update
counselors today and I can confirm that
all these grants have now been paid out
more than 300 households and nearly 40
businesses who have received the
recovery funding and our officers work
to get these grants to those in Ed as
quickly as possible working closely with
sub County Council as the local lead
flood Authority and I would like to pay
my thanks to all those involved for the
hard work in that
[Applause]
process deham was one of the worst
affected communities in suffk and so I'm
very pleased that tomorrow a flood Forum
will be held in the deham community
center where residents will be able to
hear from and speak to the Environ
agency suff County Council our officers
and others and I think this will be a
very useful event uh I'm planning to
attend the evening session to see how it
goes and I'm grateful to councelor
Davies as the ward councelor for deham
for making this event happen secondly
Living Well in Winter grants pleased to
report that mids suffk has provided
grants under the living well- in Winter
scheme to 14 projects in the district
now this grant was introduced last year
to support VC fsse organizations I had
to look this up but voluntary Community
faith and social Enterprises in
providing new accessible spaces and
activities or to expand upon existing
projects in order to provide warm spaces
and help tackle social isolation
isolation I'd like to thank all of the
people who make projects like this
happen in our communities and we hope
that this extra funding will go a long
way to supporting the well-being of
residents during the colder months and
help people to to forge new connections
within their
communities finally a tribute to Charlie
flatman we've just stood in in
remembrance of him I was sorry to learn
of the death of Charles flatman who
served as Ward counselor to I between
1993 and his retirement in
2017 but he represented the town either
Town District or county level for a
total of 43 years he sat on various
committees over the years including
environmental health housing and local
economy committees and during his tenure
he was also heavily involved in bringing
forward I Community Center working with
the town's Cricket Club and the
reopening of the Queen's head Hub
Charlie served his community with
dedication and distinction and I'm sure
that all members would join me in
sending our condolences to his family
and friends and those are my
announcements chair thank
you thank you Council
melon uh to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with Council
procedure
rules non received
chair questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure
rules none received
chair questions by councilors in
accordance with Council procedure rules
none received
chair recommendations from cabinets and
committees uh like now to move to item
MC
2331 halfe report on Treasury
management uh there'll be some officers
joining by the IBD link I
think that's correct chair um Caren
wling interem corporate manager for
finance commission and procurement and
Mike Hurst assistant manager for finance
accountant will be joining the meeting
via the hybrid
link I'd like to invite Council maton to
introd newspaper MC
2331 and to move the recommendations in
this report thank you
chair this is uh I'd like to present the
treasury management report this is the
half year from April to September last
year this is a statutory report required
by the code of practice of Treasury
management which is published by the
public sector accountancy body
sit it provides members with a
comprehensive update on Treasury
management activity for the half year in
particular it gives an update on
compliance with the joint treasury
management strategy which was approved
by Council in February
23 the the report was previously
presented to the Joint audit standards
committee on the 27th of
November and that committee agreed that
it be recommended to the district
council with the following points to be
noted in
particular that the district council
treasury management activity for the
first six months of 2324 was in
accordance with the approved
strategy and that the council complied
with all the treasury management
indicators for this period except for
one occasion when the council exceed its
daily Bank limit with
Lloyds there's four appendices that form
the substance of the of the report
appendix a which starts at page 26 of
your
papers provides some economic background
and a forecast of interest rate
movements I'd like to pause at that
point with the chair's permission and
just see if are there any questions on
that part of the
report
good
right appendix B which starts on page 31
of your papers deals with the council's
borrowings mid's total borrowing
including the housing revenue account
decreased by approximately 10 million
pounds During the
period to 113 million at the end of the
period That's to say the end of the um
last Financial year um no it's not the
half year apologies at the end of that
six months this is mostly due to the
repayment of medium and short-term loans
to other local authorities there was a
marginal decrease in the level of
long-term borrowings the period end
balance was 91
million any questions on our borrowing
for the half
year good thank you chair right then
third third is appendix
C which starts on page
35 and that deals with the council's
investment
activity mfer continued to hold1 million
pound in externally managed pooled funds
and invested other surplus funds with
money market funds short-term deposits
and call Accounts investment balances
range between 11.2 and 25 5.1 million
During the
period there any questions on that
bit right thank you very much um page 38
on um
1.16 oh sorry sorry I thought I was
still chairman and I
could I could sit down and talk oh no
but um thank you um right sorry what was
the paries chairman um so on page 38 yes
um item
1.16 yes um I I I won't I won't read it
out um but I don't really understand
what we're saying there and um what the
point of that paragraph is um I just
wondered if I could have a bit of
clarity on it ah yes I think I can
actually provide that without without
our expert assistance well done what
What's um what's happening what's
happening there is that the the
Investments um go up and down as you
might imagine and
so if they are standing a loss compared
to when we bought them then clearly
there is potentially a loss but the
override means that we don't have to
declare that loss in our accounts until
such times as we sell the investment
is that experts want correct me on any
of that or am I all right so
far that counselor you're absolutely
right it prevents the uh statement of
csil being too reactive to short-term
fluctuations so uh it confines it to the
uh reserves and uh Smooths it all out
basically makes it more
realistic excellent thank you thank
you right
so
oh
good thank you chair um we've set these
2 million pound limits for Bank balances
with Lloyd's and Barkley it's set out on
page
455 yes and I understand the rationale
behind that to to limit our potential
losses um recently published accounts
for Gateway 14 showed 9.93 one million
as cash and equivalent on the balance
sheet at the end of March and I just
wondered my question is should these
treasury management indicators also
apply to 100% owned Council owned
companies as well as the council itself
and if not why
not thank you yeah I think my my um my
understanding is is that um we would
like to actually do that and I'll I'll
ask our expert colleagues to uh help out
if that's not the case that we we could
do that and we we hope to do
it Mr though we aren't compelled to do
under legislation uh it would be a good
practice to be transparent about our
Holdings and investment companies at all
times and so absolutely counselor we are
do intend to increase our disclosure on
Gateway
14 can I can I just add they are two
separate organizations but obviously the
council does own the Gateway 14 company
so as Mike suggests for transparency
it's good but it wouldn't actually be
part of our overall Council Lo
borrowings um you will you will also see
the balance when we do what's called
grouped accounts so in our statement of
accounts we have to bring in the
pertinent balances of all our companies
into the group statement of accounts and
that will appear on the group balance
sheet so you'll also see that disclosure
in the statement of accounts
does that make sense yeah I just come
back it just it seems to me if if
there's a no if it's a rationale for
having a limit for the council then the
100% Council own company should surely
have the same
rational thank you chair um yes I think
the um yes I did finally need to say
that the um section three of of on the
Investments uh gives update on the
council's non- treasury Holdings and
that there are no changes to that
position that need to be flagged up to
members finally then appendix D which
starts at page
46 shows the indicators that the council
uses to measure and manage its exposure
to treasury management risks and the
council was fully compliant with all
these indicators um during this period
so there any questions on the fourth and
final
appendix canel which might
be yeah I realize this is look looking
backwards can you explain a bit more
what kind of modeling we do on interest
rate changes I can see there the 1% do
we do any other modeling on interest
rates we use external experts for our oh
I apologies sorry
counselor just let me to proceed
we use um external experts for our
interest rate forecasting uh they they
have there n nationally recognized as
being experts in the fields and as such
they we rely on their advice extensively
for such matters um so I answer the
question adequately well I was really
asking about whether you do any analysis
of a v so you make an assumption based
on that advice do you do any analysis on
variations from that because I think
historically we' probably got caught out
by interest rates going up a bit more
than we expected and I know forecasters
are saying they're coming down next year
but there's all sorts of international
events going on that might make them
rise thank you they Sorry Mr Hur got a
little more to say I was going to say
the experts actually provide a spread
advice they show the worst case scenario
the best case scenario and the uh the
expected scenario so they do model on
all three scenarios and give us a fair
spread uh when forecasting so we do um
forecast on that
basis
right so I would like to move the
recommendations which are on page 19 of
your papers recom recommendation 3.1
that the treasury management activ for
the first 6 months of
2324 as set out in this report and
appendices and be noted and
recommendation
3.3 that it be noted that mids suffer
District council's treasury management
activity for the first 6 months of
2324 was in accordance with the approved
treasury management strategy and that
except for one occasion when the council
exceeded its daily bank account limit
with Lloyds as mentioned in appendix C
paragraph 4.1 the count Council has
complied with all the treasury
management indicators for this period
thank you thank you council masteron do
we have a second please Council
Pat thank chair um I'd like to um second
the report um that is accepted by the
council thank
you uh I could now open the motion for
debate questions oh I beg you any more
questions we've gone through the pendes
quite thoroughly but are there any more
questions in regard to the
report no more questions could we then
move to debate
please Council
cast thank you yeah totally agree with
the proposer and seconder on this um I
do miss these half year um these
treasury management reports because
they're incredibly um informative for
what's going on at the council it's um
it's great to um it's great to see that
as as usual we're in a really quite a
good place um and every time I look at
the um CCO money coming in I just think
wow that's that's incredible that's been
that's been such a success successful
investment for us but um the I did I I
do follow also the um the actual
investment funds quite closely and
they've been sort of moving about a fair
bit over the um over the last um couple
of months and I can see them coming back
into where we the book cost that we paid
for them um especially like next month
you'll be very pleased that um shell and
BP have got their fourth quarter um
record date so there'll be a dividend
and they're talking about that being the
largest dividend so far so um happy days
for those so yeah I will be voting for
this thank you very
much thank you Council
C any
more if if there aren't any more points
i' can ask Council mat to just sum up
please and we can go to an electronic
vote thank you chair yes I I hope you'll
all be you'll be all voting for to
accept the report and um certainly some
of the points that that have been made
um here and at the at the committee and
so on will be taken into consideration
when we set the strategy for
2425 so thank
you thank you I now ask the assistant
manager governance to conduct
the electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
C penny can I
help may I take your boat
verbally four thank
you
thank you members that's 30 votes for
that's carried that is
carried like now to move move to item 10
MC
2332 the mids plan I'd like to invite
Council melan to introduce paper MC
2332 and to move the recommendation in
the
report thank you chair um the
development of this plan uh helping to
create thriving and resilient
communities in mids suffer
has been an important task over the last
few months this new Administration came
in after the elections last May with a
strong endorsement from the electorate
for the proposals that we had put to
them on the
doorsteps and in our literature we then
needed to collate and distill our ideas
down to a document which could direct
and guide the organization and our
officers as we seek to deliver for mids
suffix
residents just to briefly outline the
process that has got us to this point
last summer there were a number of
meetings between the new cabinet and the
senior leadership team where the
priorities and ideas from the green
group of councils were presented and
discussed this resulted in a draft
refresh pan being produced we then
engaged in a period of consultation over
six weeks in October and early November
this consultation was wide ranging it
involved an online questionnaire social
media engagement face-to-face meetings
with key Stak holders and also
engagement with seldom heard
voices unfortunately this consultation
period coincided with storm beet and the
very wet weather in early October which
did disrupt some of the engagement
events the town and Parish engagement
meeting in deham and the business
breakfast at the food Museum organized
by the Chamber of Commerce were both
affected by bad weather uh however even
though new numbers attending these
events were low some very useful
discussions took place so though we were
lacking in quantity of participants it
was made up for in
quality we also had a very useful
engagement session with the conservative
and liberal Democrat councilors at Stow
Market
Library following all this consultation
officers and the administration
councilors reworked the plan taking into
account the feedback and this final
refinement included reducing the number
of priorities focusing on excellent
delivery of our core services in a
financial Al responsible way and builds
in the flexibility so that the plan can
be adapted as circumstances change the
completed plan has been approved by
cabinet and now comes before full full
Council for I hope approval
today a few points in conclusion I want
to acknowledge the hard work put into
this process by Joe Hobs and the
Strategic policy team and Sarah wilock
as director and the Consultants we use
for engagement I'm also grateful to the
stakeholders and residents who gave
their
feedback secondly is this plan the
perfect summary of what the
administration wants to do no clearly
it's not but it does provide a framework
for us to work from and hopefully gives
uh direction to our offices and thirdly
the skeleton of this plan needs to be
fleshed out into delivery plans and
activities in the four priority areas
that's housing and
infrastructure
resilience Community well-being and
environmental sustain
stability in summary this plan is a
reset of the council's priorities it
helps to set that course correction that
we believe the organization needs and
that the residents of mids voted for and
can I ask that members endorse the plan
today I'm happy to propose this thank
you chair thank you councilor melon
could I have a second please councilor
Stringer um thank you chair I'd like to
Second it and reserve my right to speak
if that's possible uh after we've heard
other or if not I'll talk now the chair
wishes thank you councilor
singer um we will now move to questions
councilors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a
question good that's obviously nice and
clear thank you councelor
uh as we have no questions coming
forward we'll now move to the debate
councils will only councilors will only
be allowed to speak once for three
minutes and this will be
timed Council
Manel well if nobody else is willing to
say anything about about this plan uh I
I welcome this plan and I've not I've
not been uh part of the main group
who've who've developed the plan uh I
welcome the fact that we have
environmental sustainability as a like a
linking thread throughout the whole plan
I think we all have to be aware of our
environment and the climate around us in
everything we do uh and I think that the
plan is setting out the direction for
this new Administration over the ne next
coming few years uh it's succinct uh to
the point as has been said by the fact
there's no questions about it it it's
it's obvious what it is um and um I
think the process uh that has been gone
through to get this far involving our
communities members of the public all
all councilors here uh is is a is a good
uh step in the right direction uh and I
will be supporting this plan thank you
thank you councilor
Manel would anyone else like to add to
the
debate Council
white thank you chair well I welcome the
extensive consultation that's taken
place I also think it's a shame we can't
have a joint plan with babber but I do
understand the challenges I won't
mention parking it's difficult to argue
against the eight objectives listed
under our approach in the appendix on
page 60 I mean items three and four
should be given for any Council
providing high quality services are easy
to access when needed that can be relied
on number before ensuring we are
financially responsible with public
money who can argue against
those I do have some concerns regarding
item two putting environmental
sustainability and social justice at the
heart of everything we do I mean on the
face of it that's pretty much all of M
and apple pie type category but then the
just stop oil protesters use
environmental sustainability to excuse
their actions holding up ambulances
preventing communities getting to work
so environmental sustainability must
have some limits I'm also concerned that
social justice uh must also have some
Financial limits but then having said
all that I do recognize the greens have
been given a fuming majority at the last
election said they do have a democratic
mandate to bring forward their
priorities I will be supporting the new
mids suffer plan I help rest of my group
will whil keeping a close eye on the
administration's budgets and
expenditures over the next four years
thank you chair thank you coun W
it
um ah Council
Ricks thank you very much um I also
might surprise some colleagues I will
support this um I wish you well it's
your first plan and I think it's
important that the council Gets behind
the plan and uh see there are some
points in here I necessarily wouldn't go
with and I look forward to seeing the
next stages as it's produced and unfold
I do commend the consultation I would
just ask you to remember on points five
and six and I think it's absolutely
important that actually work together
cross party when it impacts our
residents and I would urge you to
remember that I think it's important we
do that going forward as we work with
our communities cross party for the
benefit of our residents rather than
trying to make occasional and sometimes
unnecessary political gain because this
report is about us working best for our
residents thank you thank you councilor
Hicks councilor Eber
thank you chair um thank you councelor
melan and councelor Stringer for
proposing and seconding
this I think this um plan one of the
things that we wanted to um put forward
is is remove the word corporate um
because it's a plan we're not a
corporation um we're local government
and we're here to serve our residents
and the citizens of um Mid suffk and I
think that's really important and
something we should all be thinking
about and be close to our heart
and also think that in um talking to
Residents um in the runup to the
election in May and and since it's very
very clear that they wish us to consider
more environmental sustainability and
social justice and ensure that those
things are absolutely at the heart of
everything we do and that needs to go
throughout the organization but I think
on the as a whole to me this is really
exciting this is somewhere that you know
we've been working on things over the
last um six to nine months but in terms
of actually where we're going forward um
it's very exciting to be able to put
this actually on paper and have it
really simple and straightforward um and
be really clear to what we're trying to
achieve and I for one I'm looking
forward to um various um things that we
can be doing with our residents and um
citizens in order to ensure that their
communities are thriving and I think I'd
also like to say that one of
our ethos in in how we want to work is
by consensus and we have shown this
despite um previous history in terms of
of how other groups might um work with
us or not but we've made sure that we
have um do consensus building and work
with our colleagues across all the
political parties and involve people
from the the first um instance not
springing surprises on people but
ensuring that we all work together
because we are here in this chamber for
the benefit of everyone in mid suffk and
that's what we need to be working
towards and I really commend this to
everybody thank you chair thank you
Council
Eber councilor
Walters thank you chair um yes uh I just
want to say that uh having read the
report and listen to the comments in the
in the debate um that it surprises me
that Council Whitehead uh pulls uh
number two out of our plan um without
putting environmental sustainability and
social justice at the heart of
everything we do uh future looks rather
Bleak um certainly from a local
community's perspective uh Regional and
National and Global um environmental
policies so um I personally think that
number two is is crucial and without
that uh we wouldn't be doing uh what
we're here to do
thank you Council
Walters
ad counc Stringer
oh wil Council
Wilshire
you when I read the plan I was really
pleased with the amount of consultation
and the work that's got into it I'm
really Keen to see the meat on the bones
of the next stages and the potential
impacts of that on finances going
forward you know I'm we Echo a lot of
the comments that have been made here I
think connectivity and transport should
be right up there because that's what
I'm hearing on the street and that
sometimes conflicts with some of the
environmental sustainability um agenda
so I commend all of the work that's been
gone on into it especially the
consultation and look forward to the
cooperation and across party working and
looking forward to the meat on the bones
but very good start thank
you Council Stringer thank you um I'm
not going to say too much uh which
you'll be glad about just want to take
issue with one paragraph in here uh
paragraph 4.1 says this is a refresh
corporate plan it isn't it's actually a
new plan uh and we deliberately not
refreshed an existing document we B
basically with the officers and and good
support around you know ripped the whole
thing apart and and really made it
concise uh so if anyone in the in the
room would like to put us forward for a
plain English award please do please do
uh it was one of one of the reasons we
didn't want corporate plan in there
because technically and legally we are
not a corporation uh and why should we
aspire to be one we're here as a council
and we deliver high quality services for
the aspirations of of those that we
serve so that's basically all I wanted
to say I would definitely be supporting
this this plan H and look forward to as
you say uh having delivery elements
coming forward but hopefully in the same
Spirit of working across the floor with
all of our colleagues thank you chair
thank you Council
Stringer any further comment uh Council
melon have you got anything further
you'd like to add
um thank you chair um Lacy very grateful
for the various comments and and uh the
constructive criticism we've had um uh
and I'm very pleased to hear that there
seems to be widespread support for this
plan uh let's get it through let's get
it working let's get the meat on the
bones as councelor will said and let's
see the delivery for the residents that
we all serve so uh hopefully we'll we'll
all uh vote for this now thank
you thank you now ask the assistant
manager governance to conduct the
electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you members that's uh 30 votes for
chair uh that's unanimous that is
carried I'd now like to move to item MC
2333 the Poland District review I'd like
to invite the corporate manager
electoral services and land charges to
introduce this report
thank you chair uh I'll be introducing
this report on behalf of the Electoral
registration officer uh councilors as
I'm sure you're aware the Electoral
registration officer is obliged to
review the polling districts and polling
places once every 5 years uh the
compulsory review period for this review
started in October 2023 and in line with
electoral commission Guidance the ER
undertook the review at the earliest
opportunity uh the schedule of polling
districts and Associated polling places
can be found in appendix a uh and any
changes uh to voting Arrangements namely
the poing places in which electors will
be voting can be found at appendix
C thank you uh could I have a
proposal Council
melon could I have a second Council
Whitehead uh we will now move to
questions uh councils may ask as many
questions as they wish however they must
be relevant to the subject under
discussion must be a
question Council
Mansel uh thank you chair um I'd just
like to question um the uh polling
District in my own Ward um listed on
page 68 of elmswell South uh which has
been split into two very unequal um
groups of called Elwell South 1 and
Elwell South 2 one of 25 and one of
nearly 2,000 people um they both happen
to have the same polling station and I
believe at the last election uh it
wasn't even mentioned on the on the
polling cards which one you were in um
and I just wonder why there if it has to
be split into two because there are
numbers uh too many for one uh would it
not be more make more sense to split it
equally I I don't understand why it's
such an uneven split thank
you that's fine I can I can answer that
question councelor uh so in fact it is
one polling District uh for the purposes
of AD administering the elections um The
Returning officer can split polling
districts in the same polling place to
ensure that electors don't have to queue
so elmswell South is one polling
District the numbers that are shown
there um yes you you are right they are
completely um disproportionate with each
other and uh in terms of when the
election is prepared uh those will be
evenly distributed between the two
polling stations within the same polling
place so a polling place is the building
uh the station are is the uh table of
which the elector casts their vot so uh
that polling district will be split
equally uh with equal number of lectures
attending each polling station within
the polling place does that make sense
uh thank this may be something I need to
take outside of this meeting sorry um I
I may need to discuss this outside of
this meeting um I I I have some further
questions about it so I will discuss it
with with the officer outside of the
meeting thank you Council man agree with
that thank you any further
questions um as the questions have
finished uh we'll now move to the debate
uh councils will only be allowed to
speak once for three minutes and this
will be
timed Council row
yeah I think it'd be worth um amending
the recommendations to um reevaluate one
house um ping station because um for the
development for the part of one house um
that is connected to settlement that
also contains Stow Market in parts of
the report it mentions about for other
places about the need to take into into
account excess requirements and um
currently the set up for people to go to
the polling station that is not the
nearest one and unlike the nearest one
to the um new development it's not
connected by Pavements let alone lit
Pavements which then if people are going
to polling St station when it's um gets
dark that's quite a significant
issue um the current route includes
detour Via Field with no surface of the
foot path or walking on a country road
with a Shar Bend this has potential to
make it inaccessible for People based on
dis and an impact on older people too um
there is also our priorities of making
Services accessible by walking and not
requiring people to use cars as like
where possible um at all giving them the
choice um to do that as we have already
heard today connectivity is important to
Residents I know that there is the
option of postal votes but these may not
Su everyone who could benefit from
having a PO station that is accessible
by foot it is a bit of an unclear
situation given that those consulted
would only be part of those who will be
on development in the next four years
and the number of res residents we'll
see we'll see a large increase um the
current criteria based on number of
people and Parish boundaries may be set
up to have the less accessible polling
station but with the current overall
colle Council priorities and equality
needs from information in the papers it
seems like there are further
practicalities that should be considered
as to where the polling station should
be
placed um thank you
Council response to that
Patrick
Patrick Patrick you joined us will you
be able to respond to that please um so
indeed as David said we did run the
consultation period from um October
until the end of
November um we didn't receive any
consultations from one house that
indicated any of the residents had a
need um obviously if this had come up in
the consultation we would have
investigated
it thank you
Patrick are there
uh ter C sorry Council
Carter um just regards the um having a
need when a development which hasn't
been fully uh housed yet and aging
demographic and also accessibly speaking
which anyone living there could become
disabled in between now and then and
having an accessible route overall a
inaccessible one I'd still say may not
have come up in consultation but it was
a kind of missed Opportunity by us not
thinking that it might become an issue
it's uh a new development with a a new
need with houses that haven't been
filled yet which may have disabled
residents coming in or less abled or
elderly so may be a necess necessity in
future thank you Council car I think
Council will um
thank
you very interesting on res one house
Parish has been very spread
out and Sh and members of Road
etti are not accessible to those degrees
are raising now all of those years Etc
haven't seem to been of concern and
builds that arein the Parish of one
house
equally excuse me Council Wilshire I
think we're just staying away from the
actual motion but I do realize you
desire to
respond thank
you
uh Adrian councilor bar hello um I just
I can't see floating in there because I
did have a uh an exchange of emails with
Patrick about changing the um location
from suam to St Mary Mary's Church in
floon but I can't see it here perhaps I
Perhaps it is I just can't see
it uh patri floen is in the list um also
in appendix C you'll find floting
specifically mentioned with a map on
there um containing the the details of
what is going to happen um the proposal
for floating is a trial arrangement for
the the police and crime commissioner
and then a review thereafter to see if
the um the actual trial has has worked
affected for the council and the
residents and um I do note um
councilor's uh missed opportunity um
comment um obviously one house is a
rural setting um so they they have
different needs
um and that has been like weighed in
they wouldn't not all residents have fo
paths or even lighting um so these
accessibility um criteria is is slightly
different depending on the the area that
you are in
um thank you
Patrick um are there any
other points people would like to make
come where are
we yes
please councilor Penny thank
you um I just I just like to uh thank
the the officers uh for putting
environmental considerations at the
heart of the decision that you've made
um to allow the voters of a Aon to TR
considerably less to vote now thank you
very
much thank you councilor Penny any
further points people would like to
make
um uh councilor melon would you like
to conclude this thank you chair um
clearly we we want to uh remove as many
barriers as possible as we can from
people it you know exercising their
Democratic right to vote um some people
will always want to go to a polling
station uh and and and put that P you
know that cross on the paper and put the
put the thing in the box there are other
options for people um postal vote proxy
votes uh and we obviously want to do our
best to make sure that people have the
best opportunity uh to to mark their
vote uh we we have elections coming up
clearly this year the police and crime
commissioner potentially general
election there could be byelections and
we want to get this right so as far as
I'm concerned as leader of the council
I'm committed to us providing the most
accessible uh election infrastructure
for that process and getting things
right uh in these votes in the future so
happy to propose this and encourage
people to vote for it thank you
thank you Council M I will now ask the
assistant manager Governors to conduct
the electronic
vote thank you members that vote is now
in
progress
thank you member that's 30 votes for um
that's unanimous chair that is
carried I'll now move to item MC
2334 recommendations from the
Independent remuneration panel
oh I would now like to invite Council
melon to introduce paper MC
2334 and to move the recommendations in
the
report thank you chair um I'm presenting
this uh item on behalf of the a in
monitor monitoring officer uh Jan
Robinson who's not well and I wish her
and the other members of Staff who are
not well quick and speedy
recovery um those of us who've been on
the planning committee know that it's a
lot of work uh the meetings can be quite
long the Preparatory reading can run to
many pages of documents and so there is
a substantial commitment of time for a
Committee Member and rightly this role
attracts a special responsibility
allowance now when this Administration
was formed following elections last May
the cabinet member for infrastructure
and planning Council Stringer proposed
that we slim down the planning
committees from two to one now this was
discussed and agreed with the director
and the head of planning and based on
the anticipated workload of committee
cases diminishing from the previous
level it was also proposed that we have
named substitutes to be available for
the committee I.E members who will be
ready and available to step in if a
regular member of the committee is
absent with named substitutes the idea
being they would also read the papers
familiarize themselves with the
applications and be ready and prepared
to step in if
required it was felt that this extra
responsibility should attract some form
of s and so the monitoring officer at
the time passed the report over to our
independent remuneration panel to
discuss and make a
recommendation so today we have that
recommendation on page 108 of our papers
agender item 12 paragraph 3.5 says this
in recognition of the amount of
paperwork and the additional work that
accompanies each planning committee the
independent remuneration panel is
recommending that the named planning
committee substitutes should attract a
remuneration of 20% of the remuneration
paid to full members of the planning
committee and this equates to
£63 per anom uh to be honest this is not
a lot of money but it is an
acknowledgement of the time commitment
that there these four name substitutes
will put in it's not a large cost to the
council and if of course from in moving
from two committees to one there has
been a substantial net saving in the
overall planning allowances paid so I'm
happy to propose this minor change to
the council's allowances and I ask my
colleague Council Stringer to Second
thank you
chair thank you councilman could I have
a second please thank you chair gladly
uh second uh the proposal to allow this
Sr uh um while I've got the floor I'd
like to thank all of the members of the
planning committee from all sides of
this house uh for for the diligent work
you've done uh since May because we have
introduced a lot of changes and there
has been a huge workload uh and I just
put that on record that I thank you for
all that hard work uh and and that that
we do recognize that by having these
allowances uh but then if we allow that
we have those allowances but we also ask
you to please read the papers uh because
that that's what we pay you to do and
and and and to you then to uh look at
the planning policies and make sure that
you you weigh those up diligently which
you're doing very well and as I commend
that work and I'll be voting for this Sr
thank you CH thank you councelor
Stringer we will now move to questions
qu councilors may ask as many questions
as they wish however they must be
relevant to the subject under discussion
and must be a
question no
questions uh there are no
questions uh we'll now move to the
debate Council will councilors will only
be allowed to speak once for 3 minutes
and this will be
T councilor Hicks thank you very much
I'm afraid I disagree with this in
principle the whole principle of it um
councilors are elected to read papers we
have 310 pages today in scrutiny audit
there could be many papers to read I
don't understand why you would pay
people to do what we're elected to do uh
and I think uh if you're on the planning
committee and you're a reserve you
should not get extra money for reading
papers that is the basic role of a
counselor that's what we're elected to
do day in day out and I think it's
spending more taxpayers money in a way
that we should not be spending
it thank you
councel ah Council
Manel uh thank you chair uh I um I
welcome this um special responsibility
allowance and I think there's something
that hasn't yet been mentioned um by uh
anyone yet uh it's not just reading the
papers uh members of the planning
committee also have to be uh trained and
they have to keep that training up to
date there's a minimum number of hours
uh you have to do in order to uh sit on
a planning committee um and you mustn't
let that lapse so that is another um
thing uh the substitutes the named
substitutes will need to do is attend uh
the training um I also think it is it is
it is it it has been helpful uh in
planning committee so far that we have
had a consistency of members on the
planning committee um because uh the
name substitute certainly from from this
group have been the ones who substituted
when um a regular member has not been
there and I think that provides uh a lot
of continuity um which is even more
important when cases are deferred uh
from one meeting to the the other uh we
don't have people who've not sat on a
committee and not heard previous cases
um I think it is helpful it's not a vast
amount of money um as as has been said
already savings have already been made
by cutting the number of planning
committees uh so I will be voting for
this motion thank you thank you Council
Manel Council
roow I'll be voting for this because
another thing which hasn't been
mentioned is the risk to the council if
the plan committee makes a decision that
is then appealed and the appeal goes
against Council therefore unlike quite a
lot of other situations there is a added
element to planning um that I think this
goes part way into acknowledging for the
substitutes who as has been said they
need to have the training as well as
reading
Pap Council BR thank you chair just to
say I'll be voting for this um something
that Council of bcel actually um omitted
in the list of additional things was um
site visits which from a previous um
experience I know also very time
consuming thank
you thank you
counselor he
um Council
sure no not real
sure
councelor marot thank you I was just
going to say that that as a substitute
should I be voting on
this um we have got some more training
coming up just quite a lot I think thank
you Council
Mar yeah I don't think it makes sense to
object to this on principle I think the
principal's already established that
some Council has get an allowance for
doing extra work I think the issue is is
is this a justifiable example and I
think the amount of work that's involved
being a substitute on the planning
committee is a huge amount of work uh I
don't have to do that and I'm very
relieved that I'm not doing it uh so I
think it's really just a bit of
acknowledgement of that and I think it's
important that we V this
through thank
you thank you um I'm not for this I'm
afraid the um I just can't think that a
substitute would have so little notice
that they'd have to read the paper just
in case like the morning of the thing
they couldn't go in they um they they
someone couldn't attend in my experience
there's very rarely a substitute needed
for this it's um I for me I think if you
called doing the um the planning
committee an expense a substitute should
be able to charge that cost of that
particular committee then if there's
somebody that doesn't turn up quite
often they'll read the papers every time
um and if the if the um if they're never
needed to be a sub there no need for
them to read the papers there's always
an opportunity to get those papers um
read before it's never like two hours
before a meeting so for me no I I think
this is a waste of money I'm afraid
thank you Council
Cen Council
Stringer thank you chair U just wanted
to uh just elaborate on I say I'm
disappointing that not all of the house
will vote for this uh and and see the
value in it uh it's actually quite
valuable as an insurance
policy because we can then demonstrate
that we expect every bit of one of those
papers to be read and and I know over
the 20 years I've been on committees I
have occasionally seen where I believe
that papers hadn't been read uh and and
that was a that was a risk to this
Council that was a a risk to our our
whole planning service um and this was
one of the clear
recommendations that came out of a
peerreview that said we need one of the
frustrations from our offices was some
of them were feeling that perhaps the
papers hadn't been read because we were
asking questions at planning committee
that was on page one paragraph two so
the way to do that is to say look
there's an allowance we recognize that
it's it's a it's a weighty job to do uh
and an ever increasing more pressured
job to do and Technical job to do
therefore we have a special answer
because we recognize the value of the
the weighing up of all the planning
policies and needing to be trained on
them and also the weight behind that
decision and what's also uh weighted in
that is the risk to this Council if if
someone that hasn't quite read all the
papers correctly that hasn't had all the
training uh leads to a decision where we
do get costs against us and we've had
some already um that we you that is well
worth that investment and recognizing
the time needed to make a sound decision
thank you chairman thank you
Council Council melon have you got any
further
comments yeah thank you I understand the
debate on this um but this is a uh a
paper where we're reviewing when we've
pushed it to an independent review panel
and they have come back with this
recommendation um so I'm I'm loathed to
sort of overturn it or go against it now
since we farmed it out to someone
independent um I think I'm slightly
confused by the idea that uh uh people
shouldn't be paid special responsibility
allowances for anything because the
logical conclusion is that that is you
know none of us who are doing all these
extra jobs would get anything more than
the basic allowance um clearly there's a
lot of work involved in planning there's
a certain amount of working involved in
being a name substitute being ready uh
and being available on a regular basis
being trained up being familiar with the
cases um and I think that is is
worthwhile investing in and I think this
uh this this very small allowance very
modest amount of money it's just an
acknowledgement of that and I'll
certainly be voting for it I hope the
majority will thank you
thank you coun
sir I will now ask the
assistant
coun she here Council Morgan did you
have
something I think she said just move on
okay oh now ask the assistant manager
governance to conduct the electronic
vote thank you chair uh members that
vote is now in
progress
thank you bembers that
is I don't want it to be a a dead my
vote that changes the decision but
could if you uh would like to um change
it we can include that in the minutes
okay um so but it you need to tell me
what you would like to vote please
against against thank
you thank you members so that is uh 27
votes for and three votes against so
that's carried chair that is
carried uh I'd now like to move to item
MC
2335 these decisions taken by the chief
executive under delegated powers in
accordance with part two of The
Constitution I'd like to introduce this
report which is for Notting by the
council these decisions are taken when
it is necessary to take urgent decisions
outside of cabinet and Council meetings
however from a democratic perspective
these decisions are only taken when
absolutely necessary and the chief
executive is required to report them
back to council at the next available
opportunity the Urgent decisions in this
report are for the government funding
set asite for the flood damage caused by
storm barbar the council needed to put
in place a funding policy to make sure
that funding could be distribute as
quickly as possible to those residents
affected there is is also an urgent
decision for an order under Section
911 of the Local Government Act
1972 for the council to exercise its
powers under this section to appoint two
councelors to eminger Parish Council to
ensure that the parish council's cor it
and could
cont continue to
act um I'd like to propose a
recommendation in the report and ask for
a
second
Council
won thank you chair I'm happy to Second
this I think the first item is very much
a no-brainer in terms of the second item
it's affected both myself and councelor
Dave Penny as we were appointed under
Section 91 to create a quorum to
hemingstone Parish Council Jan Robinson
who isn't with us today but I'd like to
acknowledge and thank her for all the
help and guidance she provided that
result in this particular urgent action
being taken thank you thank you thank
you Council whad the recommendation is
that the council notes the decisions
taken under delegated powers by the
chief executive unless members have any
questions I intend to put this straight
to the
vote I will now ask the assistant
manager governance to conduct the
electronic
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
counc Carter May yes sorry I'm having a
difficulty getting touching the screen
at the moment could I vote in favor
please in favor thank you very much
councelor
Carter
uh thank you members that is 29 votes
for that's carried that is
carried uh now I'd like to move to item
MC
2336 Stow Market health education and
Leisure facilities oh
shelf uh councilors I'd like to do this
item in the open part of the agenda if
possible if you ask if you wish to ask
questions on appendices A and B please
can you indicate and we will move into
close
session uh and then we will return to
open session to vote on the
recommendations in the report I'd like
to invite Council Weller to introduce
paper MC
2336 and to move the recommendations in
the
report thank you chair um shelf is an
exciting and ambitious project which has
been co-designed with several key
Partners it seizes an opportunity to
develop an Exemplar scheme on two
adjacent sites in Stow market and
delivers high value outcomes against
three of the council strategies those
being Community strategy well-being
strategy and our refreshed Sports
Leisure and physical activity strategy
now broken down into work packages
dependent on key Milestones being
achieved amongst a partnership and
aligning with funding time frames it
plans a mixture of new facilities with
enhancements to existing provision work
packet one which is being considered
today is inclusive of a new 3G football
pitch a new Mini track for athletics a
new multi-use games area or mugger
Improvement to Grass pitches including
the provision of an improved first team
pitch for St Market Rugby Club a
community track outdoor uh sorry other
Outdoor Provision including a trim Trail
and Cricket Nets um chair will be
pleased to note again and Associated
connectivity infrastructure including
improved car parking
provision this investment will enable
all Partnerships to thrive and expand
this is a model strongly supported by
Sports Inland policies and enables a
multi- agency approach to tackling local
Health inequalities well-being and
provision of services for young
people at its meeting on the 9th of
January cabinet unanimously approved the
business case and funding strategy so
the paper before Council today seeks
approval of the addition of this project
to the capital program as outlined in
the recommendations from cabinet
including the council's funding
commitment of £450,000 from the council
strategic Reserve towards the total cost
of delivering work package one so I'm
I'm happy to um I'm happy to uh promote
this uh promote this uh uh this this
proposal and uh and seek uh seek uh
council's full support of it thank you
thank you council do I have a second of
please Council Davis yes um I'm very
much in favor of this and would like to
Second um has been a long time coming um
offices have worked very hard on getting
pages and friendes together so we can be
prudent and bring a lot
thank you
counselor do I have any
questions counil can I just get uh just
a flavor without going into details
because I real we want to stay in the
public domain but just talk about health
and their commitment to this and where
we're
at yeah I'd be happy to um answer answer
those questions probably when we come to
the time when those those elements of
the uh project will be consider in
subsequent work packages they're not in
work package one but um but we are in
dialogue with um health and other
partners in relation to forthcoming work
packages thank you
Council council
heading generation artificial pitches
come with environmental concerns um
specifically the pollution potential of
microplastics in the plastic artificial
surfaces and the lot of
biodiversity um when the turf is removed
and then covered with impermeable or
semi-permeable um artificial surface
have cabinet investigated alternative
technology and materials thank
you thank you C
C thank thank you chair and thank you
for the question councelor hardingham uh
it's acknowledged that uh 3G pictures
aren't uh aren't ideal environmentally
uh there are alternatives and 4G
pictures exist and in fact I've seen
descriptions of five six and possibly
even 7g pictures as well but um but 4 4G
certainly um are prohibitively expensive
that's one thing uh possibly nearly
twice as much as the cost of a 3G pitch
uh the other thing about a 4G pitch is
that uh the footb Foundation who are
funding or in part um our 3G pitch will
not commit to funding a 4G pitch so you
wouldn't get the additional funding to
be able to support it and the final
thing is that 5G is a comparatively new
science so there's no real clarity about
uh ongoing maintenance costs for 5G
there's very few 5G pitches around at
the moment so we don't want to make a an
investment into something where it's not
a tried and tested um technology so
those are three reasons why we're not
pursuing those options it's recognized
that um the 3 is is is a less a less
environmentally sustainable uh solution
but it is going to deliver what
community needs in terms of having an
artificial pitch available and something
that we can uh something that we can
introduce into the program without uh
incurring uh huge cost to the council or
to
Residents thank you
Council are there any further
questions H Council Manel you around the
corner uh thank you chair um first of
all I would just like to say that I I am
very familiar with ch fields and just to
put the record straight I did set up a
parron there but I am now no longer the
event director at J Fields parron uh and
I think it's been removed from my
register of interests um I do have a
number of U just a few comments to make
on the report um on the environmental
implications uh section 11 on um page
122 um it does say that for work package
one there will be no Hedges or trees um
being removed uh and when I read this I
thought oh hang on a minute there's
going to be some trees removed and then
I realized it was only for work package
two um so I would I my first question is
really um work package 2 is is quite an
exciting package and I just wondered
what the times delay between um us
approving work package one and US
approving work package two uh might you
know just in sort of order of
magnitude um answer um you know is it
months years or 10 years away um and
also in environmental implications um it
talks about the car park um being
improved um I'd like to know whether
we're going to put any capability for EV
charging points at a future date in that
car park also there is a link to uh
cycle Route 51 which goes past chilon
fields and I believe some of the active
track um will also be uh using part of
that bike path um and I'd like to ask
the um uh the member if there's some
considerations going to be for um making
sure that Cycles are not permitted on
parts of the active track where running
races are likely to be taking place
thank you thank you
councelor thank you uh Council Manel for
the questions um responding to the first
one the order of magnitude between uh
work package one work package two we're
not we're not looking for there to be a
huge de delay in delivering work package
two but it is contingent on some some of
the matters that I described in cabinet
earlier and again today grant funding
availability but um we certainly expect
to be able to deliver it within within
this Administration that's for sure if
not uh if not the not if not all
packages within this or our next
Administration um but certainly the
second package within this
Administration uh the second question
was about EV I think uh EV charging I
don't think that there is EV charging as
part of work package one there isn't I'm
glad thanks for thanks for the nods from
over there so but I believe it is a
factor for work package for subsequent
work packages so it won't be delivered
in the first one uh but we'll come into
subsequent ones and your third question
related to cycling on the uh track so
the track is um primarily for uh running
and uh walking um but I've been advised
just before the meeting that there is a
possibility that that that the trat
could be used for cycling but not for
cycling as you might know it coun and
Manel but more about um training like
cycling proficiency type that type of
thing or um or uh or for people who use
adapted bicycles so that's that's more
of what what it might be intended for
we'd have to get to some of the detail I
think around that as as as we move in
but it wouldn't be the intention that
it' be a cycle track as part of the
track hope that ansers your
question thank you
Council Council
Carter thank
you sorry now I can't stop my hand from
moving right there we go um I just had
wanted a question about how does
something become tried and tested if no
one's willing to try and test it
regarding v v permeable surfaces
pictures and at what point do you
believe the council would have the funds
to pay for it it does seem to be that we
are likely to be in a favorable position
financially within a few a certain
number of years why don't we look at
extending not implementing it in this
first phase maybe extending it on this
phase later on down the line where we
might be in our financial secur position
if we are looking to be for the health
we're also looking for the environment
and anyone that's played in a free
pitch as well you like knowing the
amount of damage your cleats will do to
a pitch or you'll end up taking up at
home with you and you don't know what
microplastics end up on your clothes and
Inter that way so it's if we are looking
for the health and wellbeing it's
something we should be looking at now
even if we don't put it in first away I
did also have another question regarding
this is all phased into the Chon field
area but and I do realize that the
Pavilion isn't in phase one but the
access through I assume there may be
quite some disruption to be play
equipments fa and I don't see it in
listed in the faes I might have missed
it um and we have spoken about new play
equipment at point one point I wondered
if how we get into a question yes the
question is the play equipment it's not
what what's phases is it going to be
affected I assume is going to be going
in and out and also what stage it will
be for play equipment will be looking at
implementing on that site the children
field
side it was they were questions there I
asked her
questions thank thank you councelor car
for the question I'll come to your
second one first because I can remember
that one because it's most recent um so
um tell you what maybe I'll come to the
other one first
um so so so so so your first question I
think I'm going to have to have to refer
back to um back to back to officers but
in in relation to why is it we wouldn't
we wouldn't consider the more expensive
picture I mean we we absolutely would
want to go for the most sustainable of
course it's absolutely aligned with
where where we at where we're at as an
Administration but the cost is something
that we have to that we have to we have
to Grapple with apart from anything El
you know the the budget's been the
budget has been broadly set for the cost
of what we've what we've purchased we'd
need to we'd need to think again and
have a have another cabinet discussion
about investing a good deal more to be
able to get to be able to get that and
think about whether or not that's got a
sustainable a sustainable future in
terms of the the issues about the
technology of the pitch itself I think
that for me is a key thing about why
it's it's a tricky decision right now if
it was a well tested a well tested um
science using these then I think I'd
feel much happier about putting putting
the money putting the money behind it we
don't know what we don't know what the
maintenance costs are going forward um
but but I will invite um officers if for
May I through the chair to come in with
anything that I might have missed in
answering that
bit yes please um I'm happy to start I
might have to defer some elements to
Kate um so um the there are a few Pilots
um around to answer your first question
um but they are under test at the moment
so so there's no more coming forward
while they're being reviewed and the
findings are inconclusive at the moment
about they've got health and safety
issues for example so it would be um I
think it be quite difficult for us to
put a new facility in which has some
untried and untested health and safety
in terms of those Pilots we don't know
what the potential maintenance costs are
I don't know K if you wanted to add
anything
else
um I'd just like to add that actually
the national government bodies are not
supporting anything but 3G at the moment
um to play on for actual formalized
matches so as much as we' look to look
at sustainability options in the future
we are working with the football
foundation around that and when we put
our bid in we can make sure that we
putting the most sustainable option for
that 3G what was available at that
time oh Council w and I I'm sorry I'll
just come back to to to the other to the
other element of um of the question
which was around the disruption to play
to the play area so I think it's my
understanding I'm asking the officer to
nod at me to make sure I'm saying this
correctly that um that the pictures and
the ground workor that's been um covered
as part of work package one wouldn't be
disrupted by subsequent work packages
it's been thought out quite carefully it
was one of the first questions I had of
officers was if you're going to build a
lovely pitch then you're going to drive
a a balldozer through it in order to
build a building and that's not the case
so um so we've been given assurances
that uh that pitches will remain and
will not be disturbed by Future work
package
development thank you Council Council
Walters thanks chair um yeah I just want
to put it on record to start with that
I'm firmly for and in support of this
project as asking questions yeah okay um
my question to uh fellow uh member is um
what are the associated connectivity
infrastructure um as well as improved
car parking Provisions that we've got to
increase sustainability for phase
one thank thank you Council Walters for
the question um uh Council Walters you
you know you're part part of a meeting
where we were discussing um with
officers around sustainable travel um
amongst amongst other options actually
for reducing the impact on on on local
residents particularly during the during
the build but but also when when the
Project's up and up and running so there
is additional parking um but but there
is also sustainable travel options being
explored actively as well and I'll ask
the officers if they're happy to do so
just to support me with a fuller answer
to
that so there is improvements going to
51 which is the main cycle route through
Stow Market to make that more accessible
um alongside that we are working with
some um agreements for additional
parking at peak times which we can't go
to further detail because we're going
through legal agreements around those
but we will C confirm those um And in
regards to the bus routs we are working
with local gas providers to provide
additional provision for the
site have you have Council Walters
Council well you have anything to add no
nothing further for me thank you thank
you are there any further
questions tell about can I just make um
maybe a fairly obvious point but um what
was the think question what what was
what was the thinking that um just
remaining having a grass pitch was
discounted and you decided you wanted to
have these plastic plastic sized
surfaces and and surely it's not very
green
Council yeah thank thank you for the
question Council Mar um it's um the the
real the real reason is that uh we need
pitches for uh extended periods
throughout the year if you're playing on
a pitch a grass a grass pitch
particularly certain sports right
through the year then there won't be a
pitch anymore you'll be playing in mud
and um and I'm I'm advised that people
don't like mud anymore we don't have a
problem we don't particularly have a
problem with it on this side apparent
people that play sport don't like it so
um so in order to make it um uh a surf
surfaces that people will be able to use
and be able to use year round we need to
consider artificial services so that's
what we've had to do obviously it's a
blend of Sur surfaces we we're also
introducing grass pictures and we're as
as as I said earlier we're um extending
um and enhancing existing grass pictures
but uh but in order to have all round
all year use uh we've had to keep up
with um with what other authorities are
offering and making sure that our
residents have got access to all round
pictures and so artificial is
unfortunately the way we've had to
go if uh no further
questions
uh we will now move to debate councils
will only be allowed to speak at once
for three minutes and this will be
time
coun thank you chair I would just like
to say that I am in full support of um
the first work phase of the Shelf
project uh to upgrade the sports
infrastructure on the site um as I've
said before and I've declared this as an
interest I am a teacher at school and I
can say that the um Outdoor Sports track
and um the games facilities in this
school are in a in a very poor condition
and poor State and in really in the need
of a major upgrade it's got to be a it's
a it's a huge priority for the school
and for the community as well um it
might be worth sort of highlighting
actually that St Market High School's uh
Rugby Football and netball teams have
seen many victories and successes in
matches at home and away uh matches um
so I think this is a really welld
deserved input and investment for the
community and I hope it inspires them uh
to take up Sports um with more rigor um
I think you know as a first phase of the
Shelf project this will provide some
really much needed improvements to these
degrading sports facilities and give the
students that extra motivation to um
engage in sports uh during school and uh
after school clubs thank you thank you
coun
coun Council la
thank you chair um I will too will be
supporting this um investment um and I
welcome it um I think it's a very good
move but I'd also note um that the
council's commitment to sustainability
when it comes to spending our own money
is tempered by cost and I hope that in
future considerations when it comes to
third parties and what we require others
to do that we don't put prohibitive
costs on them uh in the drive
environmental sustainability thank
you thank you councilor Council Manson
uh thank you chair um I uh I think this
is an exciting project and it and it has
been on the cards and it's been talked
about for so long uh that I think this
is an exciting step forward in the right
direction uh whilst I think it's a shame
that we're just doing work work package
one and we've got to wait a bit for work
package two um I'm very excited about
the new Pavilion I'm looking forward to
a coffee shop um on site that serves
decent coffee uh but more seriously I
think that the uh I think it's one of
the appendices about the health
inequalities in Stow Market actually Mak
some quite Stark reading um I was quite
shocked that over a quarter of the
children in Stone Market are classified
as
obese um and and whilst there is an
awful lot of uh activ awful lot of
activities are put on uh for for
children at school and after school
clubs um I think it's also the rest of
the population um we also have to think
about I think when when when you've got
children um you know they get taken to
um to do Sports whether they participate
or not as another matter but I think
it's those it's those young adults um
and uh maybe young parents of young
families we also need to encourage
because I think they are the the
difficult group if you're not already a
sports person um it's very very
difficult to take up a new sport once
you've left University if you've had the
chance to go to university if you don't
do it then the sports clubs just want
someone who can play hockey they don't
want to teach you so I think that the
collaborative working with the sports
facil sports providers the sports clubs
who use chil field is a vital part of
this project to make sure that they are
become open to everybody whatever your
ability is you've got everyone's got to
start somewhere and if you want to take
up a new sport it's very it is actually
quite daunting and quite difficult so
whilst we have all that stats about Abes
children let's not forget that there are
adults out there who might actually want
to start doing some activity and and and
are finding it difficult so I think we
should be doing all we can to make it as
appealing as encouraging as possible so
we definitely need the coffee shop
because that's the best bit it's the
social it's the it's the health and well
the Whole Health and wellbeing thing I
I'm a very very very slow Runner I can't
run for toffee but I really enjoy going
for a run with some people I know and
then having a coffee afterwards it's the
coffee afterwards that's important for
my health and wellbeing just as much as
the running so I think this is an
important step forward I'm looking
forward to this starting but I'm looking
forward even more to work package to and
I will be supporting this thank
you thank you Council
Mel Council
wilsh thank you yes um very exciting and
I'm right there with you it's been a
long time coming um and inclusivity is
the bit that I really want to talk about
my concern obviously with cost of living
impacts Etc and the expectations of
costs and income um and about trying new
sports at the moment it's very difficult
when people are expected to pre-book and
pay in advance and that's a barrier
especially when you've got families that
are struggling and this is a potential
release to do some sports and activity
away from all of those pressures and it
is really really you know really needed
but it's got to bear in mind the
accessibility from a financial
perspective so that it is inclusive
thank you thank you Council council did
you thank you very much um I think i'
just like to pay credit and I I hope uh
have been here for some time will to
councelor Harry Richardson who actually
was behind this in the very beginning
and he was absolutely passionate about
trying to get this delivered so yeah I
will be supporting it it's been a really
interesting evening for me this evening
and I I can't say this without smiling
but I I need to so we've approved
earlier to have investments in BP and
shell we've at previous meetings uh
supported cifo which was again uh we
were always told would never happen and
it was terrible and now the new
Administration is supporting it we
supported Gateway 14 again a project
which wasn't always supported we are
voting tonight to vote for plastic over
grass which I never thought my
colleagues on the other side of the
chamber would support um and we're
supporting shelf which actually is a
really good thing so I'm absolutely
delighted to support it thank you thank
you Council councilor
White H thank you chair well I'm pleased
to see this exciting initiative which
was started by the previous
administration moving forward uh prior
to may I was saying behind the scenes
this ambitious master plan needed to be
broken out and brought forward in fully
financed packages I'm pleased to see
that although having said that I'm
disappointed that the poster child of
shelf that's the Pavilion for the rugby
and Cricket clubs that previously
featured so much in illustrations to
publicize shelf isn't now within the
first
package also although we've got no
counselors in my group now in St Market
have been advised by what I believe is a
reliable source that the Stow Market
football club are clean Keen to use some
of the facilities such as a 3G and muger
but they have not really been engaged as
consules which on the face of it does
seem rather a strange
oversight um I also wonder whether the
health part the H of the
shf will ever be delivered it's crucial
the NHS do step up to the plate and
commit to this project if it is to
achieve its full
potential but I certainly support this
overall project look forward to delivery
of as much as possible of this ambitious
overall scheme over the years and fully
support this step two step one thank you
thank you Council
W Council
cust thank you very much um um councilor
Manel says the um the cafe is going to
be a big Social Hub of this you wait
till Stow Market Rugby Club moves in
it's going to be
fantastic huge um huge fan of this um
well done for your hard work that you're
doing on this um I think
um this doesn't make you a fan of
plastic grass and I I don't think that
will become a trend in what you you do
but um I do understand the um importance
of that all weather pitch for this but
it's a
fantastic thing that we we're doing here
um I hope we can deliver the well-being
Hub because that it will be hard to
deliver but um hopefully we can do it
but I did want to speak on un parking we
do need to get that parking right
because so often I see these things and
I see the parking area extended and
extended and huge problems all around
like for residents and things like that
and I I will say that's that's so
important but yeah keep doing what
you're doing and make sure there's
plenty of um space between the football
club and the rugby club and you you'll
probably be all right okay thanks thanks
coun Council
re um thank you very much chair um the
um I wonder if councelor Caston will be
himself on the newly seeded and leveled
rugby pitch that is going to be a part
of this project because um
that's where the there' be a lot of real
grass there I can I can assure you um
and I'm very pleased to support this I
think it meets um this administration's
one of our um new um uh objectives that
we've voted on earlier which is includes
improved physical and mental um
well-being and um yes lots of the
comments about the fact that this
Project's been a long time in coming um
and yes it was started some years ago in
the previous administration
um we've in this Administration done a
lot of work in kind of going back over
that going back over the figures doing a
lot of due diligence checking in with
all of those who were um consulted all
those stakeholders um and there's been a
lot of discussions across you know both
formal consultation and informal in
order to um get as many people involved
as as possible and I'd pay tribute to my
fellow counselors particularly councelor
Willer and councelor Davis have done a
lot of the um engaging on that more
informal level um in in order to ensure
people are fully aware of what's what's
going on I'd also like to thank the
officers that um have done an huge
amount of work on this and especially as
I said in the with the new
Administration we were revisiting
absolutely making sure that what was
being delivered is what we can deliver
that the finances stack up that all the
due diligence is in place so that it's a
really robust um in terms of what is
delivered and particularly in this first
work pack package and we want to see
something happening this year so the
residents of Stow market and the rest of
the district because obviously it's not
just going to be used by residents of
Stow market so they can see something um
happening so I will be um in support of
this and um hope everyone else will
thank you
chair thank you
Council are there any further
points Council Walters thanks chair um
so I would now like to uh say that I'm
fully in support of this um project uh
at the right time um I also want to say
that uh as a resident um of Stow Market
with children that have grown up through
uh the school that councilor Pratt is a
teacher at um I Echo the comments that
the sports facilities are in um urgent
need of improvement and this will go um
a considerable way to to doing that as a
young person myself I grew up in
framlingham and uh I was extremely lucky
to have framlingham sports club uh this
is back in the 70s yeah no comments um
but uh but yeah we had football rugby
Cricket uh we had shooting we had um
Athletics we were very fortunate and I
think that our young people and our not
so young people of Stow Market and of
course the surrounding areas um deserve
uh to have that sporting facility quite
rightly being put forward um uh I would
like to Echo the comments on
sustainability and I do accept you know
that that that that has been a question
that we have debated as part of the
working group and I'd also like to
assure the chamber that we have
consulted extensively with every
possible part partner that we could have
um in the process and uh there's only a
certain number of times that you can
engage with people um before you say you
know you you clearly don't want to
engage so um I won't say any more than
that I fully support um and look forward
to phase one going through um and I too
look forward to having a nice coffee uh
when we have the Pavilion in phase
two thank you Council aors Council
Carter
on the whole I am in favor of the
project the health benefits the
necessity for improving on the health
and Leisure of Stone Market and The
Wider
area I am still on the fence regarding
the 3G pitch as there are ongoing
studies onto the potential health risks
of 3G pitches including the cost
possible cic properties of the um
compound pound also the health risk to
respiration if having Nally breathing it
in it can have a long-term effect these
are current studies
ongoing
so we have the issue of the Known
Unknown and we have something which is
currently underst study which possible
health risk may be alleviated in the
future so I'm still very on the fence I
want to vote for project I want for it
to go forward
but whilst I have ongoing
concerns and there's possibility there
that is what I am struggling with still
so this is a on the fence
still thank you Council
Carter are there
any further
contributions Council
Lindon I would like to ask you can you
give references to these ongoing St
studies regarding health risks for
plastic Turf that would be very
interesting because after all the amount
of time each youngster actually spends
on this pitch is very limited
particularly in comparison to other
environmental
dangers thank you it's we are a debate
but sorry
is are there any further points in the
debate we'd like to make
Council well would you
like have I miss anyone thank you CH I'd
like to um thank members for their um
helpful contributions uh to to debate
and and indeed questions beforehand um
to come coming to a couple of them
specifically I just wanted to raise um
come back to council's um remarks around
inclusivity and access that's absolutely
the heart of what we want to do here and
also thinking about um you know this
this is not to be this is not intended
to be um an an income generator for for
the council um so we'll be looking at we
looking really carefully at um making
sure that those that that at least able
to are able to access actually these uh
these Services uh both from Financial
point of view but also where people um
may be restricted from accessing these
services for other reasons besides
Financial so that that's absolutely key
to what we're doing the fin the um the
the environmental sustainability issue
is one that we have discussed in the in
the um working group in the members
working group um and it's been it's been
the cause of much consternation we um as
a green group wouldn't wouldn't be happy
with it um were it not for the fact that
there was an option that can't be fully
explored at the moment uh the 4G pitch
really can't be because we don't know we
don't know enough about whether or not
the um whether or not that is a that is
a a more sustainable option actually in
the long in the long term we know that
certainly at the point of um at the
point of installation it might be but
still a lot to be proved around that
matter but what we do need what we do
need to do is ensure we've got um
pitches that are available for use
because we've spent a long time waiting
for them uh we need to we also need to
bear in mind that we we need to be um
comparable with other with other
authorities nearby uh and we want to
make sure that we're attracting we're
we're one attracting uh Sports to to the
district but also ensuring that um we've
got local facilities for local people
without them having to um to travel for
them uh I'd uh I'd encourage all members
to vote for the
proposal thank you
Council um I'll now ask the assistant
manager governance to conduct the
electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you members that's uh 29 votes for
and uh one abstention that's carried
chair that is carried thank you um we're
now going to sort of interrupt the
meeting for a short Comfort break to
allow everybody just to refresh
themselves a little uh before we move on
to the skills and Innovation Center
thank you long five minutes five minutes
five five minutes
should
thank you everyone I'd now like to
continue the meeting uh we're going to
move to item MC
2337 uh skills and Innovation Center on
Gateway
14 uh at the previous item I'd like to
deal with this item in the open part of
the agenda if possible if you wish to
ask questions on the appendices please
can you indicate and we'll move into
closed session before returning to open
session to vote on the recommendations
in the report I'd like to invite Council
winch to introduce paper
2337 and to move the renumbered
recommendations as detailed in the table
papers
Al have I got the wrong one Council
Millan um thank you chair sorry sister
um um resolve any confusion um on the
papers it has me listed as uh uh
introducing this report uh I'm certainly
happy to propose it uh it was thought
that for reasons of good governance and
to avoid conflicts of interest that um
it shouldn't be proposed by the uh
anyone who's who's a a director of
Gateway 14 or the holding company
however my colleague councelor winch is
much more familiar with the the project
than I am he's been deeply involved in
this so I'm going to ask him to sort of
do the explanation but I will be
proposing it if that's okay chair thank
you do do I need to get a second or now
for no okay um so there's there's over
120 pages of background information in
the council papers as you probably have
noticed so I'm going to try and do a bit
of a summary of the whole thing and pick
out the points that I think would be
really useful for everyone to register
so I'm going to try and answer what is
it what why are we doing it a little bit
about how we're doing it uh I'm going to
touch on the financial case and then
talk a little bit about the risks
involved so what is the Innovation
Center in my mind I have three things
it's a building it's a set of service
offerings and it's a statement of
intent so the building straightforward
it's a 35,000 square foot thre
story uh building that's going to be on
the um Gateway 14 Park um and it will
have meeting rooms and training
facilities um the service offerings and
I mean by the service offerings how will
the um skills and Innovation Center get
its income longer term so the the first
service offering is office space for
Innovative companies so there'll be a
tenant policy to get the right type of
company and that will make up roughly
half of the income then there's a an
offering called um co-working which is
where individuals can work in more open
plan and networking type environment
then there's the training and meeting
room side of the offering that's about a
third of the income and then there's
something called Virtual Office which is
for companies who haven't got a front
office and there's a cafe for the uh
business park but also for for members
of the public the statement of intent is
our desire to focus on Innovation skills
and the green economy for this
District um and that leads me on to why
why are we doing it I think there's
three reasons that we're doing it number
one there's a a bit of research in the
background papers talking about skills
in the district so there's a higher
proportion of lower level services in
the district relatively low
productivity uh a skills Gap with
employers and a relatively poor
provision of skills I know this myself
I've been involved in three startup
companies one in Su one in Cambridge and
one near where I live and by far the
hardest area to recruit people with the
right skills skills is near where I live
um so getting skills promoting skills
doing skills training is is a core
element another key um element for us is
doing something about green skills so
what does this mean it means generic
business things like sustainable
procurement carbon literacy but it also
means more practical things if I took a
sector like heat pumps um the industry
is saying that in a couple of years
there'll be 600,000 heat pumps pumps
installed every year last year the
government increased the grant for heat
P heat pumps for households to
7,500 I know of two entrance to the
market this year who are planning to
each uh train up 10,000 Engineers just
in their own network so in the next few
years we're going to have see tens of
thousands of people trained up in
installing heat pumps it's an area which
we could try and get into and try and
train people so green skills and then
the last reason we're doing it is a hub
for Gateway for Gateway 14 itself to
attract new clients onto Gateway 14 and
for a facility that the clients on
Gateway 14 can
use I wanted to say three things about
the how so how we going to how we going
to build the building that's going to be
done by the Gateway 14 companies the
exact details haven't been firmed up but
the council will have a contract with
Gateway 14 Gateway 14 will go out a
competitive tender for somebody to build
that and we will have a a c price um for
the facility um in terms of once it's
built we're going out to Tender for an
operator who will Who will manage the
operations Ure we get the income and
ensure that we meet our our skills
aspirations uh we need so the council
doesn't understand how to run a um an
innovation Center so we need someone
who's got a background in this who knows
what they're doing uh and the last thing
in terms of the skills provision this
isn't something we're planning to do
ourselves we're going to do it in
partnership with other people
so um University of suffk university of
Essex West suffk College private sector
Partners where that's appropriate for
the trading and skills um so it's a
collaborative effort um on the finances
if you're like me and you're interested
in numbers I think there's two things
that would jump out straight away one is
the 18.75 million total which is a very
big number and the other thing it's
mentioned somewhere in there that the
project I can't remember the exact words
but it's something like isn't fin
financially sustainable or some alarm
sentence that's in there so I just want
to cover this off explain how it's uh
funded um so it isn't financially
sustainable in the sense that a private
sector operator wouldn't invest in this
because the long-term income is not high
enough that in itself is not a problem
because the reasons we're doing it is
not an income generating uh
project um but that does raise the
question of is it once we've built it it
on operationally it won't require
Council money but it requires a lot of
upfront funding we're going to be
funding this with A6 million pound seed
funding brand from the freep port and
then using something called pot B
business rates that come from clients
who are on the Gateway 14 free Port site
so essentially it will be paid for by
the Free Port operation and I think it's
a what the reason I think we're we're
really sort of when we first saw this we
were trying to get our mind around it it
will bring a very very substantial
investment into this District Innovation
skills and the green economy that we
wouldn't otherwise get now there is a
gremlin and that is the um potby
business rates take time to feed through
because you get it from the clients who
are on the Gateway 14 site uh and that
means that the cash flow has to be
funded and our proposal is that we're
going to fund the cash flow from the
from Council Reserves I think the total
I can't remember the exact number but
it's about it will involve about
10.75 million pounds of reserves to do
this uh we get paid that back so at the
end of the day we're getting we we are
investing in something but we'll get
we'll get all that money back um how
risky is this I just want to quickly
touch on that um we're asking for the
green light to go ahead with this
project at this meeting if you look at
three I think it's 33 in your Council
PID it says the green lights subject to
a few things the most important of those
is us getting an agreement with with
Freeport which hasn't been tied up yet
that should be done by the end of March
and we're expecting that to go ahead
because this is a win for us and a win
for them if we can't get agreement with
free Port this won't go ahead because
the numbers wouldn't make sense
um what is the Financial Risk it's very
low overall but the the the problem for
us is the longer it takes to get the pot
B business rates in the longer our
reserves are tied up on this project
that's the issue that we we we'd like to
use them for something else that depends
on us getting clients more quick more
quickly onto the gayway 14 site but
we've been quite conservative in our
assumptions about how quickly that will
happen um a couple of other things on
RIS in terms of the bill the bill is
being done by the Gateway Fortune
company it's a known site it's holy own
company by the council the development
part partner jck has done a similar
Innovation Center before so the build
risks are quite manageable in terms of
operations I've talked about us getting
an operator on board how realistic is
the income from the operations that's
been modeled on other Innovation centers
using their utilization their rates that
kind of thing so I think the numbers are
are pretty solid um there is another
risk I think which is non-financial
which is about will we get our skills
and green economy as aspirations from
this project that's really down to us to
drive through and make sure it happens
so I would I'm really looking forward to
questions on this because it took us
quite a long time to get our minds
around this um I would ask everybody to
vote for this I think it's a brilliant
opportunity for the district to get
additional money for skills and
Innovation um and I think the risks are
containable thank you thank you Council
winch uh we have a proposal Council Mel
Mel do we have a second
please Council
Davis yes um I would like to Second uh I
will be very brief and summarize that I
feel that there is a bur need for us to
have Innovation Center situated for our
local people
in thank you Council uh do you have any
question questions
please uh
Council councelor Lawrence yes thank you
chair this is a bit of a chicken and egg
question it seems to me when I support
the principle of the project that we're
building at Great cost an asset and then
we're going to go and find an
operator and when you're finding an
operator there's going to be variable
qualities of operator presenting
themselves 10 or whatever if you choose
the wrong operator the whole lot could
be a
disaster and I would have thought you'd
find the operator first before
committing to the
asset and how how if you could put a bit
more clarity on that yeah I think I
think um we're very very keen to get an
operator on board as soon as possible
because they need to be involved in the
very early discussions um we obviously
in terms of an operator we check we
check we can reference them so we're
going to know that they're okay because
we'll we'll have reference properly um
but but I take your point as long as we
get someone on board early it's very
difficult to go and and go out to Tender
for an operator if you haven't even got
approval to go ahead with the scheme so
I think we need to get approval today
and get the free Port negotiation sorted
out before we're in the background
working on a tender for an operator but
we need to get to that point before we
speak to
people councilor Hicks thanks can I just
ask two questions if I
um can I just ask when do you expect
Freeport board Freeport East board to
come to a conclusion is there a set I
think it's March the 20th March 20th
19th okay and um skills and Innovation
so I mean there's I think this great of
course I'll support it what I'm just
wondering is have we what sort of
research have we done looking at other
ones that are operating and how how
their models now finding that actually
they aren't full there isn't as much
demand as people maybe anticipated so
how have we done done that work to
anticipate how big it should be how how
big the offering should be I'll do a
quick answer and then I'll get fion to
it but the team have been around quite a
few of the other local um Innovation
centers and I think that one of the key
things that came out of that was was
issues about utilization and generally
it's much easier to to get the office
space highly utilized with with small
companies it's much harder to utilize
dedicated training facilities which why
built into this is much more flexible
space in terms of meeting rooms and
training facilities if you want
to um so we have done uh quite a lot of
research and we're constantly revisiting
uh that research in terms of um we've
visited and have an ongoing dialogue
with I'd say most of the Innovation
Center operators in the East um but we
also brought on board uh some months ago
now he Innovation uh to act as a
critical friend to us obviously they
managed their own operations which has
been very very useful generally speaking
none of those um Innovation centers are
seeing any sort of drop off actually if
if anything it's the reverse and that
they're all pretty full um but to
further der risk the project and and
this this was advised from he and
others we in our financial income
calculations we've assumed that there's
always a small a small void um and
that's for two reasons one to make sure
that we're financially prudent in terms
of the income levels um but also to
allow um space for people already in
there to move around so by keeping a um
keeping a small percentage of the space
sort of not calculated in in the total
income it gives some flexibility so
we're fairly confident that um this this
will be viable in terms of um filling
the spaces um as Council winch said the
skills element is a little bit more
tricky to uh assess which is one of the
reasons why we um commissioned a report
from resua to look at the skills
landscape not just across mids but also
across the Freeport area um and that's
obviously uh further subject to further
scrutiny through the Freeport business
case stage so I think we've done as much
due diligence as we can to drisk
it thank you very much we got any
further
questions Council
L yes I got to two very connected
questions if that is okay first I wonder
what is the price difference between
constructing a green roof as compared to
a common standard roof and second
question connected to this is the
barriers against moisture penetration in
this roof for how long will they
actually last and how do we know when
they start to end their Best Buy date so
to speak thank you very much
okay I'm glad you asked that question
because I deliberately tried not to
mention the green roof anyway it's come
on so um I can't remember the the exact
cost of the of the green roof it's but I
where where we are on this is we we've
put a green roof in the cost we would
like a green roof we're about to do
referencing on this because we wouldn't
want to go ahead without checking out
the kind of detailed questions on the
maintenance uh we will probably go ahead
with the green roof but it hasn't been
decided
yet because it it's subject to us really
because it makes a difference in the
structure of the building because if you
have a green roof you need more
strengthening so it's something that we
still haven't 100% button down yet but
we take on board that there's
maintenance issues and we need to check
that out through
referencing
C
was
Mar for the skills audit more
information about that what was
found um so the skills audit uh links
back to the resua report that we've had
done so they've done fairly extensive
piece of work looking at um levels of
skills and the uh movement in skills
levels over the last 20 years um that's
been done through a variety of
mechanisms through um talking to local
employers talking to local education
providers um for example we know that um
skills levels haven't really moved in 20
20 years in the district um in spite of
various in
interventions um and you know some some
Financial input um so we believe it
requires a bit of a disruptive model uh
to to make some difference to skills and
uh one way to do that is to place the
education providers next to the
Employers in the same building and and
that's really the uh essence of the
model unless there have any further
questions I now move to
debate um
councils will only be allowed to speak
for once for three minutes and this will
be
timed would anyone like to open the
debate councilor
maton thank you chair as no one else
will um yeah I I think the the reason
particular one of the many reasons and
advantages that Council winch has put
forward um that I'm very much in favor
of this is that the the huge
challenge um in terms of of reducing
carbon
emissions uh is retrofitting our
existing housing and and indeed
commercial
buildings
and that apart from the financial
challenge of doing that the skills
challenge of getting that done um the
the confidence of of the householder or
the business the building owner um going
ahead with that is is being held back by
concerns about about the the the quality
of what will be done and and the you
know the the business Acumen and
reliability of the businesses carrying
it out and if we can really generate a
throughput of of people with those
skills then it it will tremend ously
help the problem of
retrofittings
coun council
cast thank you chair um I I do wonder if
this green roof will offset the plastic
pitch um on the other side of Stow Mark
but no all joking aside we have got to
be really careful about that kind of
thing because by the time you've made a
building strong enough to have a heavier
roof on it you can do a lot of
environmental damage and create a lot of
carbon doing it and for me solar panels
are such
a a massively more beneficial way of
covering a roof than putting grass on it
I um I support this um I think this is a
really good idea um I think um I think
it's quite exciting I do have some
worries about it though um and um my
worries are
um that in the research in these papers
we haven't um taken into account
Innovation Labs well Innovation labs in
the University of suff we've taken into
account we haven't actually taken into
account Innovation labs in Stow Market
which is right near the train station
and I'm doing exactly what we're doing
here um I think we should um I think um
we've got to be careful that this works
whether this is the right place to be
doing this this Burns a lot of reserves
doing this project and um it's got to be
successful it's so important I want it
to be successful and I really hope it is
because there's a massive benefit from
it but when you're burning those
reserves it's hardly Canada Square in
the middle of a warehouse um industrial
estate and it's it's not got the links
of some of the other places quite near
so so yeah we have to we have to be
careful of that but um what I will say
if it all does go wrong it'd make a
fantastic Council Office in in St
Market thank
you councelor
Carter eventually right thank you um
certainly I will be a voting in favor of
this uh one of the ISS issues that we
have with uh accessibility and
disability it's very difficult to
actually find yourselves leveled up and
skilled there's been issues where
there's been leveling up uh skill
centers that have been from the job
center which have been inaccessible and
difficult to you get there a custom
built Skill Center a fully accessible
one
which I won't mention some by name but
do have someity is issues with larger
rooms of actually gaining ground it is
certainly it's a help for for those who
would like to get more skills and be
more employed um regards The Green Roof
I'm very much in favor of solar panels
but there have been studies and green
Roofing uh for biodiversity improving
and actually regaining especially
there's been some studies on nesting
Birds I believe it was on lapwing we
have with the development Gateway 14 we
did lose some yellow Hammer nesting um
grounds a green roof may actually
reintroduce some of the previous
occupants to the area so there are there
there are on ongoing benefits for both
thank
you
coun Council
[Music]
re thank you very much chair um I'll
I'll be supporting this um I want to say
that when we took this on as an
Administration We There were quite a few
holes let's say in the um in the in the
business case in terms of of how it was
going to progress and we've worked
extremely hard and with with the team
here in order to fill those holes and
actually look at a real lot of due
diligence go through the financial um
robustness of this with a fine tooth
comb um and hence the sort of changes
for those counselors who were here in
the previous administration in terms of
of how this um project is going to be
funded um because we did have to look
very very carefully um at what was um
previously proposed and we had to make
sure that that we looked at the
commercial details the financial details
and most importantly um for us has been
pointed out um many times so far this
evening the sustainability of this and
the sustainability from an environmental
perspective but also from a longevity
perspective you know we want to ensure
and I think we would all want to in this
chamber ensure that this is a success
and um really delivers as it were for
the people of of mid
suffk it's good as well to see that this
is investment in
suffk and in mids suffk and not in
another part of the country so we are
really pleased to actually support
investment in our district and I think
that is extremely important um not just
to us but to um residents and citizens
of mids suffk and with regards to the
skills um I think we've all recognized I
mean as has been shown in in in recent
years with regards to when the
University of suffk was created that
there that suffk um had been ignored
somewhat in terms of of skills
and the skills kind of services that we
needed to actually um upskill the
population and not not just young people
but we're talking about adults
retraining and so on and I think that
this will actually really fill a gap and
be very important we've got a lot of
support from um uh skills
organizations um the I sit on the fre
free Port East board and we've spoken
recently to different universities and
they're very supportive of this and can
see that what is um going to be
delivered here will actually meet some
of these skills gaps and particularly as
again something very close to our hearts
here in in the green economy and it's
something as well that aligns very
closely with obviously the Free Port
East objectives because the green
economy is something that um is a high
priority and it's something as a high
priority for for our group in particular
so I think it's good to see such a
sustainable s delivering sustainability
um across the district and I'm very
pleased to support it and I'd like to
thank again the team for all their hard
work um on this um they've um had to
deal with a lot of um probing and
questions from us and um changes to
schemes and so on and have dealt with
that um um in very um with all the very
complex details that sit behind this
project so thank you very much and I
hope everyone here will support it thank
you thank you chair well time Council
Ean thank you uh Council
patet thank you chair um I'm I'm very
much in support of the Innovation and
and Skills Center I think not just
because it's it's in my ward selfishly
but because it I think this could be an
absolute Exemplar building for the whole
of mids suffk and it gives us the chance
to actually show off who we are and put
ourselves on the map we as
Administration inherited Gateway 14
and many other projects as well and
change takes time and this is one thing
that we can definitely put our stamp on
and we can make this as green as
possible and we can make it as
sustainable as possible and if we adhere
to our um ESG you know environmental
social governance um principles we can
employ all of that into this building
and sort of really show off what we can
do and you know it may even turn out to
be a money spinner and also like Casten
said I look forward to retaining a room
large enough that we can hold full
Council meetings um in there definitely
the skills are needed in that area the
the in this whole area of mids suffk um
and currently where are people going to
do that there there isn't anywhere so I
think let's put mids on the map let's
put this Administration on the map and
let's all get behind the Innovation
Center and fully support it and perhaps
I would suggest maybe in lie of a green
roof um perhaps what we do is we have
green Walls that I've seen on some
buildings as well because that that can
look very attractive and um would
definitely fulfill our needs thank you
thank you Kel Pat
kelin thank you chair um no I think it's
an incredibly exciting project and we
know that digital and green skills are
incredibly short supply both regionally
and nationally um I also was
particularly pleased to see that um
there was a virtual office offering and
a co-working offering because I think
70% of um businesses start from home
around a kitchen table so providing
those services that help people to sort
of grow and expand in the very early
stages is really useful and then
obviously there's going to be more space
for them to grow into further down the
line so it's great that it's got that
sort of uh full variety of of spaces for
for business to grow and expand so I'd
be very happy to support it thank you
Council uh excuse me Council before we
continue with the debate uh the
meeting's approaching three hours of
duration and the guillotine rule will
apply unless members agree to extend the
meeting uh we have two more motions to
debate may I have a proposal
please Council melon may I have a second
please Council Caston could we have a
vote by show of hands
please thank you very much that's
carried Council
prep yeah I just want to briefly say
that I um fully support um the scheme um
now um not only just because you know
the the building will be exceptional it
will meet uh bre standards of excellence
and for the potential it has um you know
for training uh to sort of meet that um
uh skills Gap that uh Council mson
mentioned and also the jobs there could
potentially create as well um one thing
I would like to to sort of uh bring up
is is uh not really a question but how
this relates to um the future o
occupants that will be on the Gateway 14
site and attracting companies and
businesses within the green industry to
give you an example a lot of the green
um you know infrastructure and upgrades
that we're going to make will over its
lifetime at the end of its lifetime
create waste and some of this waste
cannot currently be recycled very easily
within the UK take solar panels they've
got a lifespan of 25 to 30 years at the
moment I believe France has pioneered
the recycling of these and as far as I
know we've got very limited uh recycling
capacity here what can we do as a
council as as many have questioned to
give direction uh to this project um to
encourage uh a company that could
potentially uh set up a recycling
facility maybe the Innovation Hub has a
part to play in that in providing the
training the Outreach
and and uh sort of uh sort of spreading
those ideas so yeah I think it's an
exciting project I think it's got tons
of potential um one one slight criticism
is it might not relate to this Hub but
maybe to the whole projects is that I
think we've missed out on an opportunity
to connect Gateway 14 and this Hub to
the town center with an underpass kez
grave style underpass so people on bikes
ebikes can walk or cycle or use quicker
means of buzzing into the town center
and bringing some economic support to
businesses and services in the Town
Center um I don't know how easy it would
be to uh do this ad hoc or
retrospectively but I I do think that
that's a massive opportunity that that
uh we're missing out on at the moment
and maybe we should uh factor in
something like this in the
future thank you
Cil Council
Ward thank you chair um um yeah i' would
agree this is a very another very
exciting initiative um it's described in
the report as a unique proposition I
visited skills and Innovation centers in
hah Hill and on the ctchester University
campus was very impressive what I saw
there one was very much
entrepreneurially driven the other
obviously had a lot of um take up from
within the The Wider campus there um so
this does feel different which is I
guess why it's called unique
um paragraph 6.9 States the scheme is
not financially viable very unusually in
a council report it's that's actually
underlined I can't remember the last
time something was underlined like that
paragraph 8.2 lists some really quite
sobering
risks um and I'd like to say this is
without going into any of the
confidential Financial details uh in the
nonpublic papers I have some real
concerns about how narrow is the gap
between the projected revenues and
projected expense
a narrow Gap means a small change in the
revenue assumption can either on the
upside increase the bottom lwi
substantially but similarly a narrow gap
on the downside could turn it from a
surplus to an operating loss um I'm also
concerned that some of the confidential
Revenue assumptions are ambitious in
terms of both utilization levels and the
charging structure so I I feel the risk
is on the downside but I I'll say to the
whole Council I'm no expert this is just
my EV good feeli looking at the
numbers um so the project could be a
resounding success both socially and
financially or it could turn out to be
an expensive white elephant that could
cost a council and there by therefore by
definition midu resident dearly in the
future and only hindsight will tell us
where it falls on that wide
spectrum now clearly I hope I'm being a
pessimist and it will be a resounding
success so the new administration's
taken over this project I sincerely wish
it well and all success but I will be
abstaining when it comes to the vote
thank you
CH thank you Council
W Council
Stringer thank you uh yeah quite
surprised that councelor white is going
to be abstaining something that he's
voted for consistently in the
past all we've done is a bit more due
diligence than the previous
administration on the figures uh and and
now you don't want to support it I think
that's that shows a frankly a lack of
ambition um yeah much has been talked
about about the uh the The Green Roof
glad you're talking about it because
that's the point others will talk about
it and there and and more people need to
be talking about what's going on in
mider because it is going to become I
believe a really fascinating and vibrant
place to not just talk about to become
and invest in um that's probably because
now this side of the chamber I'm talking
to those people that want to come here
invest and they are too getting quite
excited about what the offering is um
perhaps oh
counselor
uh I've lost and was mentioning oh c PR
mentioning an underpass uh well perhaps
uh with our County Partners if we fix
the drain that's on the road perhaps
there might be enough capacity in there
where it's all flooding to put an
underpass in there when we fix finally
fix that drain um and just to let you
know just mentioned going back to the
roof I don't keep hking on about the
roof it was a criticism that it you know
it could have been solar it is solar as
well as green uh we took advice from a
professor of sustainability based here
in sub uh to take that advice about what
we did in terms of proposing that as a
as as a design feature uh so I I say I I
have over the years been a bit skeptical
about the finances of of such an
innovation Center but sometimes you need
to skill yourself up for the future that
you're about to face uh and at least
we've provided that infrastructure if we
go ahead with this we've got the
opportunity to do it if the Free Port
back Us in March which I hope they do uh
and it will certainly certainly put us
on the map so I will be definitely
voting for this and I hope that all of
the rest of the council does thank you
chair thank you Council
Stringer have got any more contribution
Council Wich am I allowed to speak again
I'm not sure the because I'm not
the I I I think so
well we have a has spoken he hasn't
spoken you haven't spoken really you've
given an introduction so officially you
haven't spoken well there you go so I
just wanted to pick up on a couple of
things that have been said I don't like
this phrase that councelor Caston used
burning reserves so just to be clear
it's the amount of time that the
reserves would be allocated they're not
increasing over time so there's 10.75
million that we need to invest in this
we will pay that back depending on the
speed of that we get companies onto the
Gateway 14 site we are very very
confident that we'll get people onto the
Gateway 14 site quicker than the
assumptions in our numbers yeah so so I
don't don't like that phrase uh I do
think that the Innovation Center will be
really good for getting new clients on
to Gateway 14 and the right and the sort
of clients that we want um accessibility
that was mentioned it is really
important to us that this building is as
accessible as possible it's a a really
core G um objective uh the Gateway 14
connection to the town is outside the
scope of this project I think it would
be brilliant if there was much better
connectivity to the town and I just want
to pick up on this um very narrow Gap I
think after five years the reeven the
income's about a million and the costs
are about
750 if you're going to Major on skills
you're not going to get a very high
margin you could get a higher margin by
switching everything around and just
focusing on office accommodation so
there's a balance here you're you're
going to get less money out of the
skills bit but you're doing the skills
bit for the general economy and it's on
someone else's p&l that's why the
numbers look quite narrow and they're
very comparable to other other operators
in the
region um so the final thing I'd like to
say I think this is a great opportunity
to get a significant investment in mid
suffk to promote Innovation skills in
the green economy so I'd recommend we
all
for thank you Kel
Wich are there any further contributions
people would like to make Council Hicks
just to say that I kind of feel there
are possibly some gaps but I think the
positive thing is that actually I have
confidence in the board of Freeport East
who will actually look at this in
Greater detail they're investing a very
significant amount of money they're not
going to do that lightly and they
actually a lot of those people on that
board have really good technical skills
as well understanding things that you
know are very complex which this is so
you know I I feel we've kind of almost
got a scrutiny process of other people
looking at it which as well be
supporting
it thank you
C
if there are no further contributions
I'd like to ask Council melon to sum up
please thank you chair um uh I'm glad
that Council Hicks has confidence in the
Freeport board um I have confidence in
in our cabinet too and and in councelor
Ean who sits on that board and uh he's
keeping them in shape I'm sure um I've
visited a couple of these Innovation
sites um in in the in the in the
preparation uh for for this project
coming forward the one at heel uh in in
Norfork is pretty much full and they've
extended I think three times now because
they haven't had the capacity so it's
been remarkably successful also visited
the new food Innovation Center in norch
and that was very you know very new you
could still smell the paint but it's
it's filling up and it's going to have a
great future neither of these um sites
are right in the center of a town they
are out in rural locations and they seem
to work
um there's a lot of work gone into this
proposal um and absolutely uh we needed
to do that due diligence there's no
doubt this is ambitious this is
ambitious and if we're going to invest1
18.75 million pounds in a building we
should all be taking a deep breath
before we do that absolutely but there
is I think an opportunity here this
particular mechanism funded by the
Secore money for the Freeport and then
by the retained business rates is a
fantastic opportunity and I think we
would be uh remiss if we did not take it
up clearly we want the building to be a
sustainable as possible as Council padet
says we want it to speak of our ambition
as as a district and as a council would
this facility be a good thing I think
better than that I think it's
potentially transformative for the
business landscape and the skills
landscape around Stow market around mids
suffk and uh the green agenda that we
want to push forward so I'm very much in
favor of it it is a deep breath moment
but I think we should go for it and I
encourage others to vote for it too
thank
you thank you Council mam I will now ask
the assistant manager governance to
conduct the electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress uh you might have to
scroll down a bit to find the blue
line
councelor Carter may I help
you you're four thank you thank you
councelor
Carter
Penny
got thank you thank you so that is 29
votes for and one abstention that's
carried chair thank you that is carried
uh I think at that point I'd like to
thank the officers and the cabinet
members for this preparation and the the
thought and care that's gone into the
appendices that support this motion
thank
you um right uh We've now got to the
tabled motions oh no beg you pardon
we're not there yet Council
appointments uh the appointments are en
listed on the agenda are there any
further changes to the
appointments no changes could I have a
proposal Council melon could I have a
second of please Council
eburn um they are as they written I'll
will now ask the assistant manager
governance to conduct the electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress on your
app
councelor C may take your
vat thank
you is gone
yes thank you members that is 29 votes
for uh that's carried chair that is
carried thank
you uh we will now proceed to item 21A
to consider the motion on office
received from Council OT Council OT
would you like to move your motion thank
you chair uh a community rail
partnership for the switch to Cambridge
line aligns both with government's
Community rail strategy and equally with
greater anglia's goals to to promote
sustainable travel and climate
objectives and to make local lines and
stations a stronger part of their local
community it can provide huge scope for
a range of community initiatives
involving local businesses Charities
artists
volunteers and these benefits have been
proven by the nine CRPS already
successfully running across the greater
angan
region all relevant councils have
expressed their support
and greater Anglia is offering
significant financial as well as
Technical and Commercial support to get
this off the ground our own proposed
contribution is relatively
minor in terms of timing the next Tran
of access for all funding to improve
station accessibility will be opening in
April and there will be bids for
improvements along our line so this
seems ideal timing for mids suffk to
promote the
c i therefore propose the motion that
this Council resolves to work to set up
a midang community rail partnership
encompassing The Rail stations of
thirston elmswell Stow market and needen
Market this Council agrees to contact
greater Anglia to progress this
partnership as soon as possible thank
you thank you councilor Al do I have a
second Council Bradbury thank you J i'
be pleased to second that
motion
thank you
Council
um we will now move to the debate
councils will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed someone like to council
Manel uh thank you chair I I will
certainly be supporting this motion um
anything that promotes the use of the
Railway line uh that runs through our
district uh has to be a good thing in my
opinion I still remember many years ago
and I I came back uh from a a train trip
overseas and I I arrived in um in harage
and had to buy a ticket to elmswell
because my parents had just moved to
wpit at at some ungodly hour in the
morning and the chap in harage said
there ain't no station there and I said
oh yes there is having never been there
before in my life but clearly if people
in harage didn't even know there was a
station in in elmswell I think that's
pretty sad so we really need to put this
line on the map and anything that we can
we can work in Partnership to promote
the fact it's there I mean people in
harage don't know it's there all right
that might be 35 years ago but you know
people in other parts of the country are
never have heard of elmswell and thirst
and even though it's got a railway line
so um anything that we can do to promote
to promote this um fantastic uh
transport Network link that we've got in
in running through our district the
service from a greater Anglia has
improved infinitely since I first moved
to elmswell long long after that um
initial trip from um harage um you know
we now have an hourly service to to
Cambridge we have an hourly service to
IP switch um but we need more than that
because the timing are dire so if if we
can actually work with greater Anglia
and the other districts um along that
line to actually get a service which can
be used by the people who live in our
community to get to work in Berry at a
sensible time um that's what we need and
and if this is going to help us to do
that then it's got to be a good thing so
I would urge you all please support this
it's it's not a great deal of money and
if we can actually promote the fact that
we've got a railway line in mid suffk
and it is well used um getting busier
all the time we we need um to improve it
as much as we can so I will be
supporting this thank
you thank you Council M Council
R yeah I will be supporting this as well
because um as son who uses the um going
from State Market to Elm I see how busy
it is with um students people going for
work people kind of going for shopping
there's the whole there's a whole lot of
different strands to it and to be able
to get them get kind of different groups
and people involved in kind of making it
even better and kind of building on
something which is a really good thing
for the region already is a brilliant
idea and I quite like the fact of
instead of going for a kind another
consultation about how to improve things
we've looked at what works elsewhere and
what we haven't got in this area and
kind of have figured out some yeah
something we can
do thank you counil Council
re thank you very much um chair I'll be
supporting this motion um just for a bit
of History um in uh December
2018 um we um as an opposition group put
forward a motion to um investigate and
getting involved with a community rail
partnership and that um that motion was
agreed by the whole Council
unfortunately with the previous
administration that was then kicked into
touch and nothing was done so it is
great that as a new Administration we
can actually now take this forward and
and get get this going um it's a shame
that councilor Hicks has left the
meeting because um suffer County Council
have been extremely supportive of CRP um
Community rail Partnerships across the
county um but they haven't had the
opportunity to support when in mid
suffer because we haven't um asked to um
get one going so I'm really pleased that
we can do that and um would would thank
suffer County Council um in Council
hicks's absence for their support with
this um so we would it's great that we
can actually take this forward I think
it's a really um good way of actually
engaging across the district um along
the railway line and actually to make
sure that we can optimize what we what
we're doing there in a very sustainable
manner so I hope that everybody in this
chamber will support that thank you
chair thank you Council Ian Council
Carter
thank
you um thank you I will certainly be
supporting this motion um I actually
joining this we actually get not only
some Ben obvious benefits we'll actually
get a degree of due diligence and
scrutiny into projects that we may not
have had in the past with actions of
Greater Anglia um but regard we drains
by taking the drain you can actually
reduce your uh carbon up imprint of up
to
80% um by in in by improving on
accessibility and allow more people to
do train Journeys you're having benefits
of interconnectivity and also benefits
to to health and
socialization uh we'll be allowed to to
join up some interconnectivity regarding
certain projects the possibility of
opening up need and market and uh
opening up Commerce which actually more
benefits of the the district as a whole
um I will say that when I first moved to
need Market before moving Stone Market
in
2012 got on the last train from it
Market was allowed offer at a
platform and then had to go pass a
wheelchair over a fence and go down the
underpass on my bottom because I wasn't
informed up there wasn't a LIF you'll be
certainly able to actually to make sure
that the projects that have been long
since promised and still awaited it' be
nice to actually have a bit
of a bit of of an edge to help improve
things along thank
you thank you Council car Council
Davis thank
you that one thank you chair I will be
supporting this uh this motion
enthusiastically as you might imagine
representing
th it gives us that improved
conductivity and uh cats in thirston
will be very
pleased cats stands for a group of
residents that are trying to get life
back into our listed station building
that used to have be home for two
families back in the day this building
is um in various St of repair but uh
hopefully this initiative will bring
more Focus back into the the railway
that conductivity and enhance the
chances of breathing life into uh
building at the heart of our community
thank you thank you Council
Davis Council
wi thank you chair I'm very much in
favor of this very much in favor of
Partnerships and collaboration um I
think that that there's a number of
safety aspects with our uh train
stations in mid suffk that have long
gone over overlooked because we haven't
had perhaps a a loud enough voice at the
table and I'm by hoping by taking this
forward that we can raise those issues
with all the children getting on the the
school on the train at thir and the
situation with the train with the the
the tracks in need and market and you
know having to cross the road to cross
the the Platforms in Stow Market you
know all of these things have needed
long over needed of investment and um
hopefully by um joining in with um
greater Anglia that we'll see much
improvement and then greater use of of
the
railways thank
you
Council
Council L
yes thank you chair um I will be
supporting this motion this is all about
um improvements um and I think there is
nothing not to like about that um we
should be um ensuring that our
communities become fully connected to
our Railways and as Council Manel
mentioned earlier um there's a lot to
like about um some of the railways in
Europe um so I think this is a step in
the right right direction
um and for me anything that encourages
walking and cycling definitely gets my
vote thank you thank you
counselor councilor Walters thanks chair
uh I know it's not questions but I'm
just going to say why wouldn't you
support
it thank you short sweet councilor
Walters are there any further
contributions I Council
Bradbury thank you chair just a very
quick one just to say um I'm actually on
the east west rail committee um so we're
hoping if this is supported um we're
working with um greater Anglia um the
East West rail committee um which is
mainly Network rail but also greater
Anglia have an involvement in that one
the work in Hy and de has been
completed um that will increase the
number of trains and this proposal to
increase awareness of um train travel
will help that as well so thank you
I'll be I will be supporting it of
course seeing as I seconded it thank you
counselor and further comments anyone uh
Council would you like
to sum up please thank you chair yes I
very much appreciate everybody's
comments um regrettably um um a CRP
isn't the quick fix for all the quite
serious access and safety issues um that
are connected to the railway but as
councelor wilsh says I do think it will
increase our voice and and that is the
voice of local communities and people
who care about the railways and that is
really important um if this is approved
as I very much hope it will be um we
will also need um a a name for the line
so for example' current there currently
the bitten line the warry line the
Sunshine Coast line so if anybody's got
any good ideas if they'd like them to
feed them to me I I will
pass thank you very much thank you
coun thank you councelor over um I will
now ask the assistant manager governance
to conduct the electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress you do have to scroll
down the page to reach the Blue
Line do apologize Council car me to take
your
vote counc car I take your vote as for
thank
you thank you members that is 29 votes
for and that's carried chair thank you
that is
carried
I would now like to move to item
21b uh this is the to consider the
motion on notice received from Council
Weller uh Council Weller would you like
to move your motion please thank you
chair this Council recognizes the
excellent response to floods associated
with um storms babbit Karen and uh Hank
more particularly the earlier and this
motion sets out this administration's
recognition of the collaborative efforts
of statutary agencies parish and town
councils schools and very many
individual Volunteers in responding to a
number of extreme weather events since
uh since uh Middle October last year
whilst the County Council is the lead
Agency for flood resilience and together
with the environment agency has
statutary duties in connection with that
every Authority
every Community farmer land owner and
Resident has its own role to play in
protecting our people property and
infrastructure mids was enormously
impacted by storm babbit with NM market
deham framon and whirling R most
effective in excess of 300 households
and 50 businesses experience flooding
with related disruption including power
outages to many
more aside from the significant damage
to property and loss of trade to
business the social and emotional
consequences for residents can't be
underestimated
either before the water had fully
subsided that weekend I spoke with
residents in our
Villages I met the daughter of an older
couple one of whom had a physical
disability the other living with
dementia the daughter was distraught for
her
parents in their already vulnerable
position the only constant in their
lives their home was uninhabitable and
it seemed that managing in in
alternative accommodation however good
would inevitably take a significant toll
on their health and mental wealth
beinging relief schemes set out in the
council's flood recovery framework
published with the papers in this
meeting are in place to support
financially with the aftermath our
officers will continue to work closely
with partner agencies to ensure payments
are expedited and as we've heard earlier
today the last of those payments has
been made um but it's prevention and
proactive preparedness that's key to
Future protection levels of rainfall
experienced during storm babbit have
been described as a once in a 100y year
event by some sources but the effects of
climate change including flooding are
expected to be a risk of increasing
frequency so we're leaving nothing to
chance this promotion sorry this motion
promotes delivery of enhanced local
community emergency response plans
environmentally sustainable flood
alleviation measures and engagement with
key statutary professional and
representative bodies to ensure the
above by collaborative means so I'm
happy to propose the motion and seek
council's support of it thank
you thank you
Council well could I have a second there
please yeah thank you chair happy to
Second this U like councelor Weller I'm
very aware of the distress that has been
caused to affected residents and the
alarm that flooding has caused to our
communities on Tuesday evening this week
it happened that three of my Parish
councilors were meeting uh I went first
to wion Village Hall then to West then
to finningham uh and in a sense sort of
following the flow of water and the
problems down the river valley and all
three of these parishes flooding was the
top priority item on the agenda and the
issue that they wanted to raise with me
none of these Villages were flooding
hotpots like deham or Needum or Stow
Market uh but as as far as aware nobody
was flooded out of their home in those
three villages but there was significant
disruption roads were blocked with flood
water garages and out buildings flooded
driveways and Gardens covered with silt
and sewage systems backing up and not
functioning so flooding and the impacts
of flooding is very much in the minds of
our communities after these last few
months so I think it's right and proper
that we are discussing it here as their
representatives this evening this motion
therefore focuses attention on this
issue and acknowledges that everyone
that's residents Parish councils
statutory agencies and this Council will
have a part to play in preventing and
alleviating
flooding firstly this motion recognizes
the excellent work that people have done
in response to these extreme events I'm
sure we've all seen the pictures where
farmers were able to get through the
deep water in their tractors and help
tow cars out and transport people and
emergency items around these ad hoc and
instinctive responses together with the
work of the emergency services and
statutory agencies undoubtedly saved
lives and we should recognize that and
applaud
it I hope that all communities now
appreciate the need for an emergency
plan and our motion ask for the chair to
write to all parishes so that they
assess their flood risk in the village
and if necessary draw up a flood
resilience plan now clearly not all
places are going to need one but many
will uh this motion also acknowledges
that the environment agency and suffer
County Council as the lead local flood
Authority have a huge role to play in
the recovery phase and understand from
our offices that there's been good and
effective joint working between mids
suffk officers and the County
Council and finally the longterm climate
modeling shows us that heat a heating
world will mean milder wetter Winters
for this part of the country and as
we're seeing these significant rainfall
events are occurring more often so this
this winter is not an outlier it is a
taste of things to
come so from that it's clear that we
have to look at new ways of coping with
large amounts of rainfall and flood
water in some places this may need to be
new infrastructure to protect homes and
businesses but we all know that these
schemes are expensive and they take a
long time to put in
place what everyone who is involved in
Land Management would will have to think
about is how natural flood management
practices can be used over the whole
catchment as a wider a flood prevention
measure so I'm happy to Second this
motion and I look forward to the rest of
the
debate thank you councelor melon uh we
will now move to the debate councilors
will only be allowed to speak once for
three minutes um and this will be
timed Council
patet thank you chair um for those of
you that that don't know I'm actually
one of the 300 that that did Flood and
i' I've not spent the night in my house
since storm beet so I'm I think I'm
Stone markets only flood Refugee um I I
welcome this motion but I do feel it
could go further and we need to hold
these agencies to account more um you
know before during an after these recent
storms where were the environment agency
where were the County Council they were
conspicuous conspicuous by their absence
I didn't see them on the River gipping
or the river rra in Stone Market if you
look at the river gipping it's full of
Sil now because of storm beet that's all
come from Upstream who clears it out
currently no one it's still there are
islands of silt there are fallen down
trees in the river gipping and it's full
of overgrowth who's clearing that out
not the environment agency not the
County Council I go in there at weekends
along with councelor Le and councel
scarf who's not here as part of the pck
Roll Project we go in there with
chainsaws and and we clear out all this
debr the startland Street bridge is too
narrow and it's too low it's it's a
bottleneck that highways have created it
cannot receive the amount of water
that's coming down so it backs that
water up Al lo and behold houses
flood the environment agency to me um I
I feel they don't have enough care and
compassion two days after the flood I
saw some people uh near my house and I I
sort of earmarked them as environment
agency and I called them to my house and
they came down and they looked at
everything thing they looked at the
damage and they seen that I had built up
the bank to try and build in some flood
resilience not only did they not support
it they actually said that if I built it
up anymore they would actually take
enforcement action against me for trying
to protect my property um the the
environment agency are so underfunded
now and so under staffed that they
become a shadow of their former selves
they they just seem to be now just be an
enforcement agency they don't seem to be
actually an agency that does anything
I find it very frustrating myself as you
can imagine so I think rather than us
sending motions to them and sending
emails to them I think we should
actually be pushing as a district to try
and do more ourselves in these rivers
and try and take back some control so
that these rivers are actually finally
properly managed thank you thank you
Council p uh Council
Carter
thank you um I certainly will be in
favor of this motion whilst also being
sympath p and being would be in favor of
actually uh doing more if we could um
you would say that we we've had once in
a 100 Year
storm yet I don't know what calendar
the forecast agency uses but we seem to
have hundred years come up very
frequently these these days we have had
many
flood and eventss um you could actually
look at the climatic model where it's
looking at to be warmer and wetter and
depending on what model you're using
that is on the uh could be on the
sympathetic side there are some if we do
reach the sal sal can't say word
salinization point it will actually
affect the um the water flow the and we
could actually end up being cooler and
also a lot better it does depend on how
much water we get into our um ocean and
how it affects the ocean currents um so
we do need to be prepared for whatever
it be future roofing for whatever model
may be
coming um we do need to be doing more
it's not just rain into rivers it's due
diligence on behalf of um highways as
well in behalf of making sure that
drainage is uh kept clear and flowing uh
say in my ward we have flooding on a
road quite frequently um and this is on
a hill which is preventing from parents
going entering into school um it's
preventing people going to the doctor's
surgery because there's no way of
actually accessing it it's cross a road
that's quite heavily flooded doesn't
affect property at the moment but has
affected many vehicles that have been
caught out by it
um I would say is well we are getting
more flowing water flowing uh down from
uh developments and onto the surface
areas so we do need to be more looking
at more
effectively preparing for what we is to
come and also effectively um handling
what we are handling at the moment so
I'm in favor of this motion we need to
we need to support it but if it could go
further if we could do more C support
that also thank you thank you Council
car Council
maner I wonder if you could spot me
because I'm hiding behind the corner um
I I was just going to ask whether this
motion uh do does go to towards our our
local flood
Authority and and the way that they
respond to planning applications I I I
consider myself extremely lucky uh
during storm bbec because I liveed close
to the Watershed that didn't stop my
neighbor two doors down from suffering
from flooding in his garage because of a
small development that the local lead
Authority flood Authority made no
comment on when it it was a planning
application um and and and drainage and
floods are are very technical subjects
we on the planning committee don't know
very much about it and we have to take
what sou County Council floods people
say um pretty much because we we we
consider them the experts and and
clearly uh we do have a long-term
climate problem if we're going to have
100-year um rainfall every every couple
of years or whatever and and is the is
our local lead flood Authority making
the comments taking this into
consideration or not I I don't know and
does this motion actually go far enough
so that they we are we are preparing for
more rain in the future we are con
creting over we are tarmacking far more
of our land and we need to make sure
that we're not causing even more
problems further down the line I will
support this motion but I really think
we should be asking our flood Authority
um to make sure they take all these
things into consideration uh when we
have planning applications thank you
thank you Council mson
Council thank you chair uh I find that
this motion is full of good good ideas
however I do have difficulties with
paragraph two I find that is phrased in
a way that is too coercive towards
Parish councils some parishes will have
very little problems other parishes will
have very small resources and some other
parishes will obviously have huge
problems with flooding so I would
propose a rephrasing of this simply ask
for all Parish councils to be asked by
writing are you interested Ed in the
idea as per below and then they can make
up their own minds whether they want to
join and I'm sure most of them will but
some of them will not but don't make
them feel C thank you very much thank
you Council Lindon uh Council
Ro I think this is a good motion and I'm
pleased to see there's mention of um
cathal knowledge of land owners and
because um example of an issue I had in
my ward was where it took a significant
amount of time to find the owner of the
land behind some flooded um houses which
um caused significant stress to the
people who were facing who got flooded
several times and not just in stone
babet but in subsequent storms as well
and it was clear that although it's not
our responsibility and it's not
necessarily responsibility of the Town
Parish councils they are very heavily
involved when there's um events like
that and has been mentioned these are
going to happen more often so I think
it's really good to kind of try and
strengthen what like what is what will
happen and something which hasn't been
mentioned but also affected my ward was
beyond the flooded houses there was
business disruption because for example
the community center um there was staff
who weren't nearby and with blocked
roads they weren't able to get to the
community center so um at so I know the
Town Council is having to look at what
happens if staff can't get in and
there's all that side of disruption and
if people get told that they need to try
to get home at or not leave their houses
at 3 in the afternoon when they're
already at work um and just bits where
it could like there was lots of things
which could have been done better and I
think this is a step towards trying to
improve it in
future thank you counselor councelor
maon thank you chair something that's
that's I think been over looked in this
motion is that quite a number of of
parishes already have an emergency
plan and I think that um the the
second paragraph um would would better
say that that um we we ask parishes to
assess flood risk as part of an
emergency plan to improve Community
resilience generally supported by
professional experties and so on um they
don't want two plans they want one plan
that addresses the VAR ious risks that
they can identify for their community
and um so I I think that would be a more
helpful um phrasing to for the chair to
write to um
parishes uh I think Council ma said you
proposed an amendment there hav't
you I absolutely did propose an
amendment yes right got to get a second
of though
do do you have a second I think we've
got a few hands up there councilor
Carter second
councelor well would you accept that
Amendment uh thanks chair yeah I've um
I've been hastily responding to council
Linda's um comments and tying them in
with Council mat's so I've come up with
um wording that um if I can get in front
of me which I hope might address both
issues an amendment to paragraph two
reads as follows the council calls on
parish and town councils to actively
participate in in assessing flood risk
in their communities that will take
account of those that may already have
done one we know that several have um
and to work collaboratively with
officers to develop or enhance all of
their local community emergency response
plans not just in response to
flooding I think that would
uh that that that would be my suggestion
for an amendment to that to to that
paragraph Council M yeah I I'd be happy
to second that form of words
chair thank you um thank you Council we
just try and record that
now so uh we need to get councelor melan
to um approve that U motion Amendment
please I'm happy with those amended
words I think it does um improve improve
the motion I'm grateful to the two
members who made those suggestions thank
you thank you members
um you would have to debate the
amendment and we have to V we don't need
to oh we can go to a vote oh sorry we
don't need to go to vote sorry it's late
I do
apologize
um yeah councilor
Lawrence
concern
um I'm sorry I'm sorry that I didn't get
chance to speak before the change in
motion to me it makes no difference I do
not support this motion while paragraph
two is in it at all the reasons are it
hasn't been costed the production of
these plans who's paying for it I know
council's going to assist there's been
there's no support of costing the
require of producing these plans or even
enhancing the
plans drains have not been cleaned
ditches have not been cleaned Rivers
have not been dredged and flood Plaines
have not been created what what are they
supposed to put in their flood
resilience plans Parish councils have no
ability to change any of
that none of the um the danger of such
plans is also that um these flood plans
or elements of flood plans in other PL
will identify areas of flooding which
are not recognized in flood zones how
does that cover Property Owners trying
to sell their properties or
Insurance Parish councils don't want
more bureaucracy and documentation
landed on them they require Solutions
and actions by existing agencies which
have the authority and expertise to do
so what I would suggest is a flood
resilience plans I know we have water
surface plans requirements for
developments but I think developments
over certain developers developing a
site over a certain number of properties
20 30 whatever they should be required
to reduce flood resilience plans um for
the areas where they're building which
would be more than just a water surface
management plan for their site so I will
not be supporting this motion while
paragraph two is in it at all thank
you
Council Point Council
Pratt yeah um I not sure I'll be able to
convince Council Lawrence to change his
mind but this is a a motion which is
just basically a call for Action rather
than a a sort of very detailed plan or
sort of costed plan as to as to what
would follow it um I think I think it's
a brilliant idea of course it has many
limitations things that you speak about
are really kind of perhaps even in many
cases more important issues um but a lot
of those are outside of our remit uh
with suffer County Council and with the
environment AG agcy for example so um
and and I I do agree that it will
probably cost quite a bit of money for
for parishes to conduct uh hydrological
surveys or risk assessments and and
perhaps some funding will be needed um I
I do however think it it's really really
worth doing uh I can you know I can
think of a few situations without going
into too much detail uh where where this
would be helpful to sort of um you know
uh improve um safety and and sort of
help uh reduce um the impact of flooding
and save and maybe even save lives uh so
I think it's a great idea I think um you
know alluding to uh what councelor
Patrick was saying there we do need to
also put pressure on agencies to make
sure that water courses near urban areas
are kept clear and that the water can
flow but it's also about um as I think
Council Lawrence also alluded to
actually you know getting land owners
involved and and setting up
opportunities for um for water
attenuation as well so it's a huge it's
a huge and complex issue but um I think
this is a this is a good initiative
thank you thank you Council P Council
Wich yeah I had about 20 residents who
were flooded in my ward and I'm very
happy with the with the response in
terms of the flood recovery Grant and
we're about to go ahead with the flood
resilience Grant a little bit late for
me but we're about to do that so that's
really good but on top of that 20 got
loads of people who are really worried
about this and if I look at the flood
I'm not sure who I'm addressing this at
but the flood investigations that that
the county coun are doing we've got
about 50 people on there and what
worries me is that they're saying it's
going to take two years to get through
that process now I understand why
because it's a huge amount of
Investigation but there's are so many
people in my ward and that'll be true
around all the wards who want a bit of a
rapid this is this is what you maybe
could do this is how you could get
together with land owners this is the RO
forward whatever it is and I'd like to
see in parallel with the detailed
investigation that takes years some kind
of
Rapid Outreach to the to the areas
affected saying this is the sort of
thing that you could be
doing thank you councelor councelor
Stringer thank you chair uh given the
word infrastructure is in my uh title of
of my portfolio I thought I'd better
just say a few words um I think this
yeah I I think the wording of two is is
sort of interesting some parishes might
take that as as an insult I would
imagine because a lot of them already
doing work and they do some really good
work but I think we need to write
something and and perhaps we could
refine those words one thing about
having putting flood plans into
emergency plans please don't please
don't an emergency plan is something you
hand to the uh blue light Services when
they arrive if you've had a major road
accident or something the flooding thing
is a totally different response to an
emergency plan U an emergency plan
assumes you you get to the village hall
there's power in it etc etc what we
found out during the floods you couldn't
get to the Village Halls because
everywhere was cut off so a flooding
plan is something very different to your
normal emergency plan that said um I
think we've got to look at the art of
the possible now we're up against
weather events that are terribly extreme
and getting more challenging we
recognize that the statutary agency
doesn't have enough funding to do its
job properly we also recognize the
County Council who the floods Authority
now used to be us as the district
council it's now that it is stretched
financially and therefore out of all of
the major events that were needing
section 19 notices after the recent
flooding they' Whitt it down to a list
of just over 100 started off as 12200 so
what happens to the nine other 900 other
events that need to be sorted out they
won't have the funding to do it or the
capacity to do it we won't have the
funding or capacity to carry out the
work but at least what we can do is work
with our parishes to inform us of things
we might be out to work to get those
quick Solutions while the longer
Solutions have being worked on we
actually did it in menam a couple of
weeks ago I spent Sunday afternoon
wandering around misham with Parish
counselors poking sticks in drains
having a look where the problems were we
found four other problems that nobody
ever knew existed but we also found two
solutions so that's the point it's using
those people that are now energized to
want to go and formulate a bit of a plan
it might be a bit Rough and Ready it
could form part of their neighborhood
plan and heaven knows it will help
inform us in our planning decisions what
was remarkable though wandering around
the Villages those larger schemes that
have had subsystems put in them every
single one of those subsystems I looked
at worked so congratulations planners we
got that bit right what it did didn't
work though is where they fed into those
older systems collapsed absolutely
collapsed because one they hadn't been
maintained householders hadn't cleared
out ditches they filled in ditches
without piping in all that kind of stuff
needs to be unpicked and I don't think
the County Council has all the res all
the resources the environment agency
certainly doesn't we don't have all the
resources but at least we can open up
that conversation with our parishes to
work on a bit of a plan I'll be voting
for this motion thank you chair thank
you Council
Stringer Council
Elin thank you chair um I think in my w
every Parish flooded including my own
very small village which doesn't even
have a stream um so I don't have any
problem with um section two because to
me all it does is call on Parish
councils to assess if they do have a
flood risk which I think is a sort of
reasonable thing to ask people to do and
councelor Lawrence has point about the
cost um I agree it can get very
expensive and complicated um again in my
Village a little group of homeowners who
flooded Parish counselors a few other
interested residents are getting
together around a kitchen table to uh
talk about what we need to do we've been
out I think we've stuck our heads in
every drain in the village now uh my
Glamorous Life um so that's what we're
doing we're mapping where the drain
system is we're looking where the
problems are we're helping older
residents who can't clear out their own
drains and ditches so it can be very
sort of simple and and free basically
and and sort of address it won't address
the really big problem like we saw in
deham but it can do an awful lot to help
sort of small communities be a bit more
resilient and cope with the sort of
force of water that we know we're going
to keep experiencing unfortunately again
um but I did want to just second what
councelor winch said which was the sort
of urgent need for sort of hopefully
fairly quick access to some expert
advice because I've got one very small
village who have got very supportive
farmers and land owners who are happy to
to try things that haven't been tried
before to try and reduce the flood risk
to the
Village you know having holding ponds
moving where ditches are things like
that but they don't want to do something
that's going to make it worse further
Downstream uh they're very small
community they don't really know where
to start with it so a little bit of sort
of Rapid Fire response of sort of do
this don't do that would be enormously
helpful and they don't really want to
wait two years and risk getting flooded
out again you know potentially multiple
times before they can take some action
so I will be very happy to support this
thank you good sir
right I I'm just going to ask Council
whad now for two words
to two words um yeah well I was
certainly concerned about paragraph two
I mean we all know what our Parish
councils are like we attend the meetings
and I could just see myself in a March
meeting where under correspondence
received the clerk would turned to the
parish council and said got a letter
from the chair of the mid suffk and he's
asking you volunteers to develop a local
flood resistance plan he's suggesting
weeks after you put your precept in for
the next year to go out and get
professional advice and expertise and
they're very they very happy to assist
in mids suffk and I think of a parish
counselor and every one of my Parish
counselors who would just say tell them
to and uh that's the reality I mean most
of them would say we we pay national tax
tax we pay our County Council we pay our
mids suffk district council tax you know
why should us as as volunteers be have
that ownis task put on so I'm certainly
concerned about paragraph two the rest I
think I can
support thank you Council W Council M
well could
you okay thank you Council
La um thank you um thank you thank you
for the um thank you for the useful
debate um I've I've I've suggested an
amendment which I think we can agree
with hope um to paragraph two
um so that we're not doing two but we're
making a request of parishes I think
councelor Elkins made a really valid
point there around how um how actions
needn't be expensive they they they can
be very local to what people understand
as being their local situation and
derive Solutions arising from that when
I went to councelor DAV
um uh Village uh during during the flood
uh I don't know how comprehensive their
plan is they was they were really
significantly flooded but that Community
came
together uh incredibly fast incredibly
effectively and uh and with uh with
great compassion for the people that
were effective by flooding in that
village now I don't know whe they had a
plan in place or not that that that made
that happen but um I think there's
lessons that can be learned from there
around um how these kind of um
Grassroots type um Solutions can be
derived without great expense and I
think that's kind of what we're what
we're trying to encourage um and not
withstanding the roles and
responsibilities of the um staty
agencies which we agree they have and uh
councelor Patrick makes a good point
around um us putting pressure on them to
do their jobs and to do their jobs
better to do their jobs faster but I'm
mindful of the fact that officers um in
mids suffer District Council have a
relationship with them had have enjoyed
a relationship with those agencies
during during the height of the um
babbit in particular and uh through the
emergency sort of team that stood up um
during these during these types of
incidents secured secured some some
support from them um orbe it um with the
limited resources they have maybe not in
such a timely way as you might have
hoped so I think um I think the idea
here is not to is not to
um not to not to kick not to kick
Authority who's trying its best with
limited resources by which I'm talking
about the suff County Council um but to
but just to articulate Our concern that
that we're that we're reflecting that
are our residents concerns in this forum
and um and put some put some proes in
place to uh to deal with them
collaboratively as much as we can
thanks thank you
Cil councilor
Davis um I thought that I I better speak
being from deham um although it is quite
still heightened emotion in deham with
regards to this um in answer to the
question we did have an Emy plan it was
an old emergeny
plan nonetheless people got together
that were on that old Emery plan and and
that is exactly what I think the council
is asking people to this motion today
and and that is to look around you and
see what you have in your parish and
what you can and can't do and find and
proactively find out what information
you need it is one of the reasons why
the um Forum um has taken place tomorrow
in deham because I asked for it and
pushed for it and phoned up the County
Council and phoned up the environment
agency and spoke to his people and said
we need to hear from you what we can do
and what we can't do and what we expect
you should be do and what you shouldn't
be doing and I would encourage everybody
to come tomorrow to um ask their
questions out this forum because at the
end of the
day we were worse to hit we will be
going over what happened deam but
nonetheless there will be issues that
are common amongst all parishes and all
Villages of what can be
done thank you councilor
Davis um time is marching on I would
like now to ask
[Music]
the Deputy Governor
to proceed with the
vote uh thank you chair um I'm just
going to read out the
amended that's that's fine chair I'm
just going to read out the amended
paragraph two um which now reads this
Council calls on parish and town
councils to actively participate in
assessing flood risks in their
communities and to work collaboratively
collaboratively with officers to develop
or enhance all of the local community
emergency response plans braacket not
just in response to BL to flooding
bracket
end
the vote is now in progress and this is
the substantive Mo vote that um
substantive motion that you are voting
on thank
you
thank you member that's uh 27 votes for
and that's
carried all thank you very much members
um just a word of caution before you get
into a ditch to clear it please remember
to take a short ladder with you speaking
from
experience um right
uh thank you again the next meeting is
on Thursday the 22nd of February
20124 at
5:30